welcome ladies and gentlemen to the i am not a
gm speed chess championship brought to you by
chess.com we have a very exciting matchup for you
today which we'll get into in just a moment first
of all i am grand master daniel merdeski and
it is my pleasure to bring this match to you
together with the one and only ginger gm
grandmaster simon williams simon how are you
doing on this lovely morning slash evening i'm
doing very well yeah thank you for that lovely
introduction daniel um it's not so lovely
in england i should say it's wet it's cold
it's raining it's dark so it's a good time to
be commentating so it's it's great to be here
commentating with you daniel and yeah what should
be a very exciting match awesome well i'm joining
it's also a great day in charlotte so gray all
over the world but not on the chessboard because
the players today are going to make sure that it's
not grey we have a match between uh women's fm
alicia sanoramo and international master roberto
brida we'll get into we'll get to the players
and their pedigree in just a moment but
first let's take a quick look at the format
uh just a quick refresher so the bracket will be
elimination matches so the winner of each match
transitions on to the next stage and as should be
familiar to those of you who have seen i am not a
gm mattress before this will be usual 75 minutes
of five plus one uh 45 minutes of three plus one
followed by 25 minutes of bullet each segment with
a one second increment that's very important and
breaks in between uh now the players are not just
playing for honor they are playing for very very
significant prizes and uh it doesn't matter where
the players are everybody earns a prize but simon
900 for the winner there is a lot at stake here
and uh the players are bringing their a game each
and every match yeah definitely i mean uh there's
been some great matches so far i i i love the last
one you know i love danny but i love lawrence
as well and that was so so exciting and um i
hope this one lives up to all expectations um we
should note as well that it is a sort of handicap
match because of the the difference in rating but
the last time this happened was between greg and
um that that was ambotes and that came down to
a one-game finish it was just in one game so i'm
expecting yeah another exciting exciting event
daniel it's gonna be fascinating and they they
both look to look a bit psyched up there don't
they you can see concentration on their faces
indeed both of them and they're looking snazzy too
i like that that uniform and uh indeed a 15 point
uh 15 point head start for alessia but alessia
is no pushover and blitz a lot of the viewers
probably know her as a streamer she streams very
frequently on twitch she has a large following
she plays a lot of blitz so not only is she an
experienced blitz player but you know when you
stream a lot you you become more experienced
playing in the limelight and we've seen in not
only this uh i am not a gm championship but all
sorts of speed chess championships the ability
to play under pressure the ability to play when
you know thousands of people are watching you
uh should not be underestimated simon i i don't
know if you agree with that but i think that might
play a role here oh well i totally agree with that
daniel i mean i i have some very bad nightmares
of uh uh of playing ben feingold with with far
too many people watching and uh yeah that's that's
something i try to i try i still have a bit of
rehab for but um there's a lot of pressure when
when people are watching you play blitz um it's
it's extra pressure and you can get very nervous
you you don't want to do silly blunders you're
aware that if you make mistakes you wouldn't
normally do everyone's there everyone sees
your mistakes and obviously in the internet
age people are very critical as well so um so it
is it's going to be very interesting yeah i mean
i i don't know how the match is going to go
but also 15 points is a big league it is yeah
and and roberto can't afford too many mistakes
the problem with blitz is there's always that
that margin of uncertainty you know anybody can
miss maiden one anybody can blunder their queen
uh but roberto a a name that might not be quite
as well known to some of the viewers but he is
an extremely strong blitz player uh i saw that he
leads a active youtube channel and i i saw that he
recently posted he crossed 2800 blitz on chess.com
that is nothing to sneeze at and i remember him
playing on various sites for many many years so
he's got quite the blitz pedigree as well and he's
a very solid international master he's been an im
for many years uh and together with the ability to
play in the limelight experience also really helps
so i'm really looking forward to this matchup the
games should begin any second now as the players
you can see alessia you can see some nervousness
perhaps uh in the players faces but once the
game settles on you know you usually find them
full focus mode all that jitter's gone yeah it's
it's jumping into action isn't it and getting in
the right frame of uh you know mind to play uh but
i i i agree alicia does look a little bit nervous
um at the moment but i'm sure that will disappear
as they get started um and yeah i mean i follow
a lot of her streams actually she streams
quite regularly in the mornings in the uk
so a famous stream we've done a bit of commentary
together before but roberto going over 2800 i have
to admit that's something i've never done so he's
clearly a good player i know it's something you do
for breakfast daniel you know 2800 blindfold i'm
you know you're an awesome blitz player but thank
you it's um it's it's gonna be very exciting just
this odds match and the way it's set up but if
you're gonna pick one player who would you go for
i'm sorry put you on the on the spot here daniel
but it's nice to have to do that simon i'd have
to i can put my prediction out there as well um
it's tough i mean i i would say you know this is
not necessarily yeah it's going to be very close
i think 15 minutes is a lot though alessia
is an experienced blitz player i feel like
she's putting a lot of practice i think it's gonna
come down to the wire i think it's gonna come down
to the bullet i'm i'm not sure how either of
these players fares in bullet so i'm going to
okay i'll have to go with alessia but i'm gonna
have to put a big caveat here that uh roberto is
clearly an extremely strong blitz player so
i think if alessia can keep a five-point lead
or more going to the bullet she's got a very good
shot if not i think uh roberto has the better shot
i'm very bad at predictions also so ignore
everything i just say well you kind of left
it quite open there i have to say that was that
was very like if this if that so basically they
could right yeah exactly that was crafty that
was crafty very enlightening perspective as usual
no no it was good so good to back both sides i
mean i i mean i i you know over 2800 it's massive
but it is 15 points i mean i'm gonna go that
alicia is going to hold on and and win this one
uh but i think it's going to be incredibly close
and i i think you know bearing in mind another
thing alyssia has got to think about is game play
and in the five segment especially if she's losing
maybe she should drag the time on a little bit as
part of the rules right i mean resigning pretty
poorly is something she shouldn't do and that
they're off daniel they are off and they have a
queen's gamut of the first game you're absolutely
right simon this is a timed match and you know
some people tend to frown on late resignations but
hey that's completely within the rules milking the
clock you do it in other sports you do it in
basketball when you milk the shot clock and
there's no reason not to do it in chess but let's
jump into the action roberto with the white pieces
in game one just to remind people 75 minutes of
five plus one to begin that's a pretty leisurely
time control when you think about blitz you think
about 30-second chess being popular nowadays
lots of time here comparatively speaking to thing
because we have a kind of a queens gambit and this
might transition if alessia takes that pawn
on d4 to an isolated queen spawn uh type of
position which of course is very very typical
but roberto can also be the one to take on c5
yeah it's always i always find it very exciting
and interesting to start these matches daniel
because their openings will have a major influence
on their score obviously and it's very hard to
know when to adjust your openings when to change
openings and a lot of people only have one opening
so we might see in this game straight away if
alicia is going to get in trouble in the opening
and if she does will she be able to change or is
she going to be struggling with the black pieces
throughout this competition so i feel this is
the first couple of games a good way to see how
they're going to size each other up um because
you don't want to get in bad positions every game
this is one thing daniel wrench unfortunately was
doing against lawrence in the french lawrence was
just crushing him in the french defense in in
the five-minute segment i don't know if you saw
that daniel but it it was it was pretty horrible
some of the positions that um you know that was
happening there so yeah i saw a couple yeah they
weren't pleasant were they they weren't pleasant
they used to call him danny french but then
the french committee decided to take away that
that nickname okay i forgot i said anything but
here alessia is spending she's almost two minutes
in by move nine she was thinking about whether to
accept that sacrifice on d4 instead she decided to
cast a complete uh her development and keep the
tension now the ball passed into roberto's court
will he take that pawn on c5 one common idea to
take that pawn on c5 and then to fianchetto the
other bishop this is also a very typical move d5
basically compelling black i would imagine to take
that pawn and then we're gonna see this bishop
and sconced on d5 i would say a slight ever so
slight edge for white here uh alessia could
try bishop b6 but then she'd have to reckon
with the weak pawn bishop g4 instead pinning the
knight let's see how roberto responds to this one
yeah it seems like a very solid start to the game
um i mean i think uh i mean it's interesting to
know what kind of strategies both these players
should be you know trying to go for i guess alicia
having the 15 point lead i would recommend
that she she just tries to play quite
solid chest doesn't you know you have to avoid
blundering at this time limit obviously or try to
but don't don't play anything too too over the top
just get long games in until you have to take your
opportunities where you can and what would you
suggest let's say you're a robertio's second here
what would you suggest that his strategy
should be for the the five minute segment
i mean definitely i think aggressive he needs
to try to win every game in the five minute
because in the five minute portion you have
that time to think you have a little bit less
uncertainty in the three minute portion and
especially in the bullet you have to allow for
for some freak mistakes you know you have to
allow for some blunders in the five minute you can
you can take your time you can really focus
on trying to outplay your opponent and
given the head start roberto has to try his best
to do that to sharpen the position when possible
to take some calculated risks but as you
said not to go over the top for him either
so we see a trade of dark squared bishops has been
offered if alessia takes that bishop then white's
queenside pawn structure is is slightly ruined
uh nothing major though and white does get that b
file for one of his rooks so we see quite
a few trades here the position quite tame
but uh i'm beginning to get a little bit
worried here about alessia's clock now two
minutes almost two minutes and counting yeah
it's a bit of a worry i mean like you have
to get yourself into the match and get getting
the right rhythm i think is very important not
moving too quickly but not moving too slowly and
finding that rhythm and adjusting when the time
segment changes is going to be another big
factor i think it's okay at the moment but
if it gets down to the one minute section then
then you start panicking right then you have to
up the tempo and to be fair it's not such a
complex position this one it's one position where
you probably should be moving a little bit
quicker because there's no outright tactics there
maybe this is a sign of some slight nerves on
alicia's side um but hopefully she gets over
them quickly yeah and she needs to decide whether
to take this fish i mean she can what you can do
is take and perhaps simplify the position further
with 95. uh something like that comes to mind but
you can also defend the bishop with with the
move like queen e7 either way she's got to make
a decision because yeah the time disparity is
huge she does take that bishop let's see what
she does here maybe bring the rook into the game
just rook a to d8 comes to mind as well um again
like you said simon yep and that's exactly
what she does the position is simple enough
not that much is going on tactically speaking uh
but white definitely has that slight edge now what
roberto needs to decide i think is is he going to
play this move g4 get rid of the pin but accept
some sort of weakness of his king side
maybe maybe g4 queen c4 something like this
uh pretty committal decision though so uh he's got
something to chew on as well and we see that he is
chewing on that yeah i mean he's got he's got
a lot of time on the clock he's got nearly well
two-minute advantage really what they're
about so he might as well i mean the thing
that i think everyone watching this must bear
in mind when they're playing chess as well
it's time management is so important in in blitz
or in long play and if you've got obvious moves in
the opening you should generally be moving quickly
there's no reason to think but every chess game
will have i'd say like one to three critical
moments and it's those situations where you
need to tank a bit of time and work out what to do
because they're the ones that are going to change
the effect of the game so you've got to manage
your time well play the obvious moves quickly and
i like what alicia is doing here daniel putting
the rugs on that open file playing logical moves
getting ready to double up seems like uh it seems
like a nice plan that she's she's now found here
yeah i like that quite a bit and uh if roberto
tries to secure his bishop with c4 then he gives
up the b4 square always important when you make
these pawn moves what squares are weakened as
a result and if white stick or flex sticks the
knight on b4 black's going to be very very solid
here with no pressure down the b-file so roberto
has to find alternate arrangements uh for that
bishop on d5 maybe an airbnb somewhere but it's
not exactly clear where uh okay that was not funny
at all if you move the bishop away then right now
daniel sorry you keep putting yourself down with
your jokes your jokes are good i'm liking it okay
you've thrown some good jokes in already you know
you see i'm used to commentate with robert hess
and and he's very mean to me so i'm not used to
being nice to you thank you we want more jokes we
want more definitely i appreciate that i'll do my
best so but roberto here uh the computer's showing
a small edge for white i'm actually not sure
if uh in human terms white is actually
any better i mean i'm not seeing a very
satisfactory response to work f28 we see that
reflected in the clock roberts are taking
a big big chunk of that time advantage to think
this situation through what is he going to do here
yes i'm i mean it's it's not obvious here
at the moment i mean it's a very simple plan for
black and the other thing you want i think when
you're playing blitz chess i don't know if you
find this daniel i mean you're one of best blitz
players around but for me certainly i think for
most most mortals is simple plans or you want to
have positions which you understand well in the
middle game so you can play your moves really
quickly you know you don't have to you don't have
to think too much and queen c4 now played and this
does look very logical to at least get the queen
out of that pin and to pressurize the pawn on c5
but that bishop takes f3 is a very good move
i think alessia is going to follow it with 95
trying to simplify the position further that was
a very important resource because the c5 pawn is
saying so roberto might actually consider taking
with a pawn i know that sounds weird but at least
that way you preserve your bishop if you take with
a bishop after 95 that leads to a further trade
and you know as we discuss the more the position
simplifies the easier it is to play for black
and roberto does take with the with the bishop so
let's see what what will happen i'm thinking even
rook takes d1 and 95 is fine or 95 immediately
although that might lose a pawn to rook takes d7
so rook t7 is probably going to happen counter
attacking black screen we think this is going to
happen then alicia might take with the queen and
white might be up upon here it's not the best fun
but maybe some chances remaining for
roberto who's chewing on this situation
yeah and now look at the time i think the
time is going to now going to be a major
factor in this game to be honest i mean
they're they're both got 30 seconds i know
they're getting a bit of increment every
move uh one there's only one second though
and they're gonna have to now change their
tempo they've played quite slowly to this point
sometimes you have to sacrifice the quality of
your play just to play some quick moves right uh
and alicia thinking here i think that move knight
takes f3 should have been played a bit quicker
yep white now taking over the file but so far
alicia's holding hasn't played any mistakes
doing very absolutely and this should be with
correct player draw but i doubt it will be somehow
because it's just uh anything could happen bullet
chess hyper bullet being played here 20 seconds
for both sides and we can just see five on
five well not on the same flank but equal
material rook and queen nothing major happening
i would just take this and go rook to b8 rook
to b8 push that pawn through that's exactly what
alessia does operating with confidence blink pass
roberto now with less time spending a little bit
too much time in those critical moments it's b4
is black better here even possibly the king
definitely bring that king and king to c5
black king makes it in time and roberto's got
to think about making a draw here definitely i
mean c7 though rook c7 lots of counter play on the
board yeah okay i think i shouldn't have allowed
that move yeah i'm sure yeah i mean behind a
passport normally a very important thing to
do but the white rooks become active and with
little time on the clock here 10 seconds left
she's got to make an important decision do you
give that away she's given the pawn roberto not
taking it yeah bringing the king behind now rook
to d8 maybe take active counter play two seconds
she's got gotta make a move yeah she's gonna she's
gotta make a move oh and now roberto can win that
b3 pawn although it still remains within the
bounds of a draw oh she gotta move oh on a flag
oh we can see the reactions there already she's
laughing that one off but i mean that was that
ending because even roberto roberto was kind of
shocked there i think alicia played fantastically
until allowing that rook into the seventh rank
and she just didn't up the tempo quite enough
but positive play from her up to that point in the
game absolutely incredible middle game play great
decision making and it really came down to the
wire you called it simon you know when you've got
five seconds for player something's bound to
happen even in the most dry dry of positions but
you know alessia remaining positive she's telling
this as a victory she's doing what she needs to do
you know taking the games down to the wire and
she's going to pull some of them out here we see a
one e6 followed by a b6 so they've transposed into
this semi-french semi-owens game kind of opening
and uh leslie adopting a very sensible set up
having played f3 but uh black now wants to play
c5 in these positions and break apart white's
pawn chain so a very common response here is
to play f4 in order to meet c5 with knight f3
and keep that e5 pawn well protected instead a3
the bishop just comes back no i mean you would
often expect that bishop to exchange itself on c3
like in the french defense doubling uh white's
pawns there but uh black's decided to keep that
bishop i mean again you have to sort of decide
what structures you favor when you pick an opening
and um i really like this move knight to e2 and c3
i think this is a very clever maneuver you can see
white's pawn structure b2 all the way to e5 those
pawns are so strong and if white can you know
maintain those pawns in the center of the board
i i do certainly prefer white's position here
absolutely and we see that this has indeed taken
on the contours of a french bishop a6 trading off
that french bishop the infamous french bishop and
and that is a very very typical idea in the french
um and roberto doing a good job sort of forcing
alessia to make decisions uh constantly you know
should i trade the bishop should i ignore i don't
think that's particularly essential and i like the
speed with which alessia decided to take it play
f4 she's playing very sensible straightforward but
uh healthy moves and white's definitely got the
edge here yeah certainly it's nice having a space
advantage in such a position i was thinking maybe
alicia could have played before at some stage
because i suppose there's a long term plan here of
black of pawn storming on the queen side with a5
and b4 and white could have taken control of both
sides of the ball possibly white's got control i'd
say on the king side with pawn on f4 but having a
pawn on b4 you've got space advantage everywhere
so um this is a very blocked position now the
pawn structure when they become locked like this
it's a lot of maneuvering that's going to go
on not some quick tactics but getting your
pieces to the best squares and now alicia's
gone for this b3 and this is a this is a very
i'd say in some ways double-edged positional
choice because you can see a c3 pawn is is quite
weak in a lot of positions uh i'm not sure if that
was the way to play or not would you have played
b3 there daniel yeah it's interesting because it
i agree with the assignment i think i'm not sure
who the opening of the queen side favors but it
seems to be black another idea that i indicated
with an arrow a queen trade would favor black here
because white seems to be the one trying for this
king side attack with f5 so queen c4 a timely
and there we have it uh right on cue queen c4
alessia correctly declining the queen trade
but now look at black's queen entrenched on
that square that is a huge asset and now roberto
trying to get his knight to b5 attacking that c3
pawn which uh of course now can be attacked with
the c file being opened maybe a4 alessia should
consider to stop the knight from getting to b5
another very important thing in blitz prophylaxis
stopping your opponent's plans that can be
so hard to deal with in a blitz game instead
alessia going for king g2 trying to go rook h1 but
simon not sure that that's a very effective plan
if she does play rocketrone because black
can always cover a check on aj with bishop f8
i totally agree i like your a4 move i mean chess
is about two things pushing your own ideas but
you need to stop your opponent's ideas and uh
i think this knight maneuver that uh roberto
played there was very clever and if white could
have stopped it white should have stopped it but
i do have to go back to this b3 move i mean there
is a rule which is well worth bearing in mind i
mean i think b4 you could say breaks the rule
but in general you should play moves pawn moves
on the area of the ball where your weakest this is
just like a general rule and because black's got
the space on the queen side and white is going for
this f5 break you should avoid playing pawn moves
opening up the area of the board where your
weakest and i think alicia opened up that
area of the board and it's only helped black and
i think here she could just be in a bit of trouble
she definitely is and as we indicated
this check on h8 it looks scary
but black simply goes bishop f8
and and there's just no follow-up
and and to compound that problem black is taken
upon but every subsequent trade is in knight f8 is
also possible every subsequent trade is in black's
favor alessia also stands to lose this a3 pawn
and if she does black's gonna have two connected
passers on the queen side this is looking
very very grim and again a big time advantage here
for roberto who's kept his clock over four minutes
that's right and um okay so trying some check i
mean you can't even grab that pawn if white tries
to grab that's an evil idea very nasty and this is
the kind of oh did she play it she played it and
this is one of those situation talk about
should she even play on for a minute here
because every minute she gains on the clock you
know she's got this lead because it's a handicap
match it's part you know you're allowed to play
on i i feel like maybe she should at least play on
here i know it's people can say it's morally wrong
but it's in the rules so why not you never know
yeah part of the game i think i think
it's part of the match it's legitimate
i think she should try to take on on aa take that
rook maybe go f5 stir some things up you can also
wear your opponent down by by being resilient in
these positions even if you know you're gonna lose
uh just forcing your opponent to think a little
bit and here we see alessia taking her time
again she's nothing wrong with that every second
is gordon she's having a nice sip of tea there or
something just she's saying right i'm probably
losing here i'm just gonna maybe also it's good
time to have a think about what what your strategy
in the opening should be because of course we now
know she knows what happened in game one so she
could be thinking okay now i'm gonna have black
in the next game if the opening goes the same way
what what do i need to do differently if i lost
that first game so it's a good time to sort of
reflect on positions you've had even on because
you don't get much time to do that when the match
is in your face um but she is playing on here
there's a capture on f5 it looks like it's going
to go two games up um but still a long way to go
i mean this segment you can see the the the clock
ticking down there's still 56 minutes left daniel
uh it's a lot of games they can get in at that
time definitely but looking at the score it's only
gonna be two to fifteen that is indeed a long road
to climb and unless they're trying her best to
just throw things up but she's just down too
much the queen queen is the queen of the queen
and uh yeah you know i took her q took a sip of
tea and um just gotta gear yourself up for the
next game i like your point about thinking through
the openings if you are taking this time it is a
good idea to think through okay what might i be
doing not as well what could i be doing better
what do i need to tweak uh you know any kind of
small things that you could be telling yourself
could have a compound impact later in the match
so yeah and this one's gonna be in the books
now 2 to 15 is our score and yeah 55 minutes
left in the five minute portion plenty of time
and they're off for the third game so okay well we
have a change of opening here in the first game uh
roberto played the queen's pawn up and now going
into what's called the english opening um and an
opening i've played a lot and i i think if you
played the english daniel a bit as well you're
you've played everything haven't you don't i've
played everything a few times but my question is
have you played the english because it's called
english or is because you like the positions
is it like an obligatory thing for english
grandmasters to play it i i think it has to be
i think i think you should always play an opening
from the area of the country or from well now that
i'm just thinking what what could be a really
bad choice there i mean i guess french people
play that you know there must be a bad choice
but french people's play the french dutch people
should play the dutch what's the what's the worst
choice i'm just trying to think the worst name
the worst is named after a country yeah is that
iran the russians pretty solid that's the petrov
russian is not a bad choice um yeah because
there is a great choice spanish is a great
choice yeah if you live in spain you're doing
well because there is that um there is that
saying that any opening named after an animal
is just terrible so you got the elephant yeah
you got the orangutan yeah so but i think after
a country generally openings with a country name
are better right they're they're they're
more sort of that i can't think of any bad
ones off the top of my head yeah i can't either
i think the people of that country would rise up
you know if it was uh not a sufficiently sound
opening yeah right now people people are saying
the hedgehog is a good opening well you know
it's okay but it's not it's not fantastic either
um but back to the game now lots of things
happening here already i i love that licia
puss in that h-pawn because i love it when harry
the h pawns going up the board but but also you
also have to be careful your center right daniel
and i'm a bit you know you should only be able
to do wing attacks when you're controlling
the center of the board and i'm not sure
that alicia had that center under control enough
to get a way of doing a wing attack really yeah i
mean oddly enough she played h6 and then after b4
oh wow the pawn is untouchable dude now she played
h5 so i'm not sure if that was a mouse slip or
or if she decided to respond to that move b4 with
h5 but this end game is is actually really really
bad for black for several reasons first of all
you hinted at this alessia's king and one of the
biggest misconceptions is that attacks are off
the table in an end game that's not quite true i
mean this is more like a queen less middle game
black's king is uncastled and not out of the woods
another thing that's tough and that's why i really
like the move rook v8 that frees up that c8 bishop
which didn't used to be able to develop because b7
would have been hanging if i were roberto now
i would try to strike in the center as quickly
as possible attack those puns and that is what he
does with that a4 attacking that e5 pawn certainly
we've got to remember here this is the kind of
position where you could try to castle as black
um but you can't because you moved your king i'm
pretty sure i've done that before i get into a
position i forget i've moved my king i go to i
go to carlson like what's wrong what's wrong with
chess.com it's not allowing me to cast a second
glitch we discovered i've done that even over
the board where i i wasn't sure if i could castle
so i started furiously hunting my scoresheet okay
is there like a zero zero there no and yeah it's
a terrible feeling when you realize you've like
taken a queen on move two and then move the king
back to e1 no castle there was a there was a
famous case of this in uh you know some of the
strongest players in the world i mean i i think
this is roughly how the story went it went with
uh courchenoy courtroom was one of the strongest
players never to become world champion i'm sure a
lot of people out there have heard of him there's
a film recently over him fighting uh in 1978
for the world championships against karpov and
in one of the world championship cycles um when
you when you try to get to play the world champion
simon sorry wait wait a minute yeah i think i'll
say just what happened i think she just now slips
bishop b3 oh dear oh dear oh and she grabs her
head yeah that and roberto kind of raising his
eyebrows there all right i'll take it yeah okay
i mean this is looking like it's gonna go 15 free
so far yeah but sorry not to interrupt you no
no again i think this one caught snow basically
he was one of the best players in world time
and he had to get the arbiter and he had to
ask the arbiter am i allowed to castle queenside
is my rook allowed to castle through the bishops
diagonal so he wasn't even sure about the castling
rules even though he was one of the best players
in the world and the arbiter had to tell him the
rules there uh okay but freeno up in the match
and it'd be good to see alicia get back into this
one and we see a french defense she got a very
good position as white in the last game can she do
it again i think she should play exactly the same
opening absolutely well but not this b3 move yeah
if it ain't broke don't fix it she had a great she
had a great opening and uh like you said i think
if she focuses on the king's side in this game she
would have every chance to to get an even better
position so here we go f3 i like that choice and
maybe roberto will modify his opening strategy
a little bit because i didn't like his position
there but bishop g5 i don't remember in the first
game i think alessia developed her bishop to e3
yeah she's going for a slightly more aggressive
setup here which does make a lot of sense that
knight is now in a pin meaning it can't move
and also white has possibilities of using
her center here and alicia might be able to go
e5 putting pressure on the pin but she's now
just maneuvering the bishop around does black
want to play g5 looks a little bit a little bit
over the top the move g5 but he's played it he's
gone for it and he and i think as you said daniel
it really is roberto who probably needs to take
more risks because he needs to win more games so
he's he's got a he's got to stir things up and
he he's done that with g5 but obviously daniel
very double-edged move because the black king it
doesn't want to castle king side now because you
pushed your pawns away and it would be lacking
any protection right but this movement g3 that
may not seem significant but it does help roberto
get this knight to h5 now knight takes g3 is a
you know it's a significant positional threat
you don't want to give away this bishop
uh because that creates a weakness in these dark
squares but the problem is if you go bishop f2
then black plants the knight on f4 that doesn't
seem like a big deal but it could be annoying it
could force the other bishop to f1 and um alessia
with this decision she goes knight g2 but now
roberto is almost definitely going to snap up that
bishop uh maybe lsa is planning to take with the
h fun and open up that rook on h1 that would be an
interesting approach and then castle uh queen side
you don't see that every day so roberto's got to
decide is it worth it uh to give white that h file
i think it is i think you should take that bishop
probably worth grabbing the bishop i think i
mean again unbalance it this is the other sort of
natural move isn't it daniel you can play because
black was the problem with black's position
white's got these two very strong pawns in the
center of the board and black doesn't really have
any control over the center so a move that roberto
just played tries to get some influence in the
center and and complicates the position somewhat
so a free i think looks like a very
good response so forcing that bishop
now to to give itself up i'd imagine on c3
um and we're going to have i mean was there
a bishop d6 there i was wondering as well was
interesting but oh this sort of uh gave this
as a possibility didn't it that that yeah that
actually was a pretty serious possibility just
planting that bishop they're stopping black
from castling that bishop is very hard to kick
away i mean it's right in the middle of things but
black is no good way to to chase that bishop away
and and it could combine perhaps with a with a
knight on c7 that would have been very unpleasant
so yeah and now bishop d6 even here might be
pretty good i like him i like it i like it
see i think this bishop f2 this is a a classical
sort of i i hate to say but mistake but you should
always look for the most active move always and
retreating the bishop there when there's a more
active possibility you know it's not the right
way to go so always look at going forwards as
long as it's sound of course and this one i think
it's still okay for white daniel i still prefer
white's position looking funny but i like the idea
of going straight into black's position as well
no absolutely bishop d6 was was very strong
but white's position remains very solid and um
the problem with roberto's position is he's
over extended himself slightly he's weak on
both sides of the board i would just castle if i
were alessia talk the king away and go after you
know one of black's many vulnerabilities you could
try to get a knight to b5 that's exactly what she
does she's playing this very very well d takes
c5 also an option just opening up the position
if i were roberto here i'd scramble to finish
my development maybe go knight c6 try to get
some clarity in the position also which should
be mentioned knight b5 here oh that looks juicy
and that bishop on a5 not to be underestimated
either that could be trapped this is a perfect
situation to throw the knight into the position
get it into d6 that square where the bishop is and
also you have ideas of going c3 and b4 trapping
the bishop will she play it and this is this
is the perfect time to play it because you've
controlled the center developed your pieces got
your king castle you've done all the basic opening
things you're into the middle game when you're
in the middle game you need to start playing
proactively creating frets and there we have it
and now she's got to find an act to follow
maybe take on c5 you mentioned the idea of
c3 the problem with something like that might
be a6 so white has limited time to follow up on
this i would probably take on c5 trying to get
that line of fire going between white's queen
and the d6 pawn so for example dc bc and then
something like bishop c4 trying to hit where it
hurts trying to attack that d6 bond further and
alessia takes on c5 so what is your running run
opening up the position and now
it's can she okay so bishop c4
and the only downside of playing this is of
course the bishop can now come back to c7 that's
true where black has this defensive strategy
in the center she's gone for your plan though
i think she's playing this game very well i
think her nerves are gone you know no matter
what the result she's doing all the right things
okay the king comes up that's a nice move though
i was going to say where does the black
king go in this game there's nowhere safe
for the black king so this is a safe
it's going to get you don't always
need to castle sometimes it's safe for
leaving it in the center behind the pawns
and uh now white's got to decide what
to do i mean can you play g4 bishop g3
this kind of craziness is this the way to go
because you want to be aggressive here don't
you daniel if you can now that you've moved that
king uh keep the tempo up against black's position
and f4 i really like the spirit of that move
alessia trying to open up this diagonal for the
bishop so for example knight takes f4 knight
f4 gf and she's going to give a check on h4
further weakening that king f6 maybe you can
strike with e5 we're gonna see some fireworks in
this game but roberto a6 very level-headed finally
gets rid of that knight and now he's he's a little
bit more free to deal with the opening of the
king side i would take that pawn on f4 because
that also establishes a square on e5 for this d7
right that could be a pretty meaningful outpost
that makes sense okay the knight
goes back i mean again retreating
if you can avoid it you should probably avoid
it and now it's very published with the opening
of the f-file you've got i mean this is this is
whose king is safer here yeah i like it i like g5
certainly certainly luckily
there's bishop g3 i guess all right
a bit of a save but it's one of those kind of
hidden moves though isn't it d5 the queen on b8
suddenly strikes all the way across the board and
if you're not if you're not on the ball you could
easily miss that queen takes h2 uh idea there
um okay so she's moved their knight now to g3
you know i i would be thinking night knight e5
is a lovely square for that night isn't it yeah
and queen g a queen h7 could also be made
with a problem 36 seconds that's what really
concerns me it's such a complicated middle game
yeah and burning more clock on every move here
it seems to me that roberto has overtaken the
initiative that king on e7 now looks perfectly
safe and as robert s always points out snyder on
g3 very bad situation the knight is completely
circumscribed by a pawn that pawn on e6 guarding
f5 and queen g8 here that now would be a great
time for that and he does it yup yeah it
does look like the black king is now well
defended and if anything it's the white king
but the time situation is the major issue here
even though alicia has played very well roberto
has defended brilliantly i have to say there's
loads of times he could have gone wrong and uh
in this situation alicia has got to up the tempo
still very unbalanced if i was white i'd be trying
to maybe get my queen to the center get a you know
or try to attack on the f file but there's no
obvious way uh this is going to achieve so much
here so it's the time just keep an eye on the
clock i think most important one um love it'd be
great to see alyssia get it get a win on the board
you know as well at the moment she is free down uh
how much time do we have left in this segment got
41 minutes but she's played a very good game here
absolutely and she was very close
knight b5 one got the sense that
she was very close to delivering a fatal blow but
roberto finding some very creative approach to
the position here we see the position remains
very complicated i don't think white is worse
i love the move b5 alessia continuing to attack
in g4 the position just explodes anything can
happen but 10 seconds on the clock this
is going to be so hard to to survive in
and this is this is a really strong
move in your opponent's tiny trouble
that doesn't seem great because now the rook is
extremely king yeah ghgh knight g4 is going to be
a killer yeah the white king now has proven to
be the weak king and uh this g4 is such a good
mood to play when your opponent's got no time on
the clock because defending against such an attack
you have to be so accurate if you don't find the
right move you're just going to get checkmated
which i think is going to occur here one second
down this is looking pretty grim now yep and
roberto is going to pick up a bunch of pieces
here rook takes h3 is going to come in as well
and this one is just over upper rook and yeah d5
is also perfectly good bishop's coming to life now
right yeah but you know what i hope alicia takes
something away from that game because she played
really well i mean okay she lost roberto playing
well of course but uh alicia was on the offensive
there was pushing that opening that she's playing
is giving her lots of good positions and she needs
to keep playing that one so just she will get a
win if she keeps doing that i'm sure absolutely
but uh before anything else happens we are going
to go on a very short half time we're going to let
the players catch their breaths and we're going to
catch our breasts it's been very very exciting so
far and the best is still to come short break
and then we will return for the second part
of the five minute segment of this i
am not a gm speed chest championship
matchup
welcome back to thechess.com i am not a gm
speed chess championship we're in the midst
of a very exciting match between international
master roberto molina and women's feed a master
alessia santoramo we have the second half
of the five-minute segment coming your way
in just one moment simon your thoughts about
the match so far your thoughts on the players
respective chances as they settle into this
match i think there's pos positive things from
both sides to be honest i mean roberto is looking
very good he's looking like he's handling his time
better than alicia and he's keeping the pressure
up he defended well in the last game uh but
alicia is getting good positions especially
with the white pieces the she's just gotta
i guess i don't know just use you focus a little
bit more and use her time a little bit better
i mean the way it's going um i'm trying to work
out in my head the odds of roberto catching up
alicia so there's a 11 point lead we're only in
the five minute section and if it does continue
this way then i think he will probably be favorite
but let's hope alicia gets a win on the board soon
absolutely and if she continues to play
aggressively especially the white pieces
you know roberto might save a couple of those
positions but one time out of four or five i think
alessia will find the moves necessary to uh to
finish the job and we see another english here uh
the first time roberto played the english things
didn't go that well for alessia she had played e5
now we see that she plays the more queen's
gambit set up and and here we see a nimzo
indian name so anyone for the first time in
the match which line we're about to play e3
very reputable one of the most popular uh
responses to the nimzo indian and knight g2
yeah so this is a pretty solid start from from
both sides here and i think it's clever choice
of roberto playing the english we're talking
about a lot of this is sizing up each other's
openings trying to work out where you're
getting the advantages and um roberto did
get a crushing position from the english in the
first game this is more positive from alicia but
slightly cramped here uh hence why she's crashing
out with a5 i mean it's the kind of position where
you know your pieces can lack oxygen to
breathe right when you're playing with black
look at alicia's pieces on the queen side she's
got to try and do something with those with those
pieces there right and oftentimes what you'll see
in these positions is the bishop comes out to a6
and uh you get this kind of cat and mouse game
who flinches first waiting game black's other
idea more active idea is to eventually get e5 in
as you said simon get a little bit more breathing
room a little bit more oxygen for your pieces
uh what are white's ideas white's ideas are are
generally to kind of just push black off the board
sometimes you'll see an attack on the c6 spawn
i know that pawn doesn't look meaningful
right now but you know mark my words
uh there are certain positions where this fight
it is a backward one and it can be attacked
in some you know future reality in 2028 by a queen
that perhaps lands on a4 so we'll see how this
plays out i love what elise is doing here that
bishop on c4 beautiful and it can be supported by
b5 when black can just chill i i don't really
an e5 instead that also seems pretty sensible
i think alyssia are playing very well in this game
i think she's doing things perfectly in actual
fact i mean i was talking about her queen side
pieces she's put that light square bishop on this
perfect square and now this proactive move i like
this e5 because it's it's very tempting just to
sit there and not be proactive but if you've got
a chance to grab the initiative then take it and
she's played this move and also her time handling
much better than this exactly i was gonna say yeah
it's good it's very positive sign so far yeah over
four minutes and i think during the break you know
one of the biggest challenges in these matches
is pulling out the positive you know taking the
games you lose and saying well this is what i did
well this is what i want to repeat uh it's not
all about starting from a clean slate every single
game and i think alessia told herself you know i'm
i'm making the right moves i'm playing with the
right kind of style i just want to play a little
bit faster trust myself a little bit more and
that's exactly what she's doing in this opening
as we see roberto taking on v6
he's the one who flinches first
that really liberates a lot of black's pieces i
would take back probably with the queen so that
uh that knight could come out to e5 and threaten
bishop d3 with a pin but i mean obviously you
could also stick with the knight that also
seems pretty yeah she takes for the knight
i like that a little bit less because now roberto
is going to stick a knight on d4 and that c6 spawn
what did i tell you now that pawn's going to cause
black a little bit of problems here but rook c8
uh black is still completely fine yeah it's a kind
of yeah brook c8 maybe at some point black can
play c5 but then you then you have a problem with
your other right in the middle of the board so
this is this is the situation both of
these black pawns they may look quite safe
and when you're trying to attack a pawn structure
as white's doing it's always a good idea to look
at the base of the pawn structure which
pawn is holding up those pawns it's the
c6 pawn at the moment white attacks that if
that pawn moves the other pawn becomes weak
and um you know this is this has gone a little
bit better now for roberto here but still nothing
too serious for alicia very solid position nothing
immediate should happen at the moment no immediate
danger to either side yeah i'm a little bit
worried about e4 and that's exactly what he plays
for yeah and yeah now his pieces get out
bishop to f4 knight to f5 the problem is
um if if alessia and i can maybe show this on
the analysis board if alessia just takes it's an
instructive moment just take everything on e4 what
you see is that once that outer shell disappears
the position collapses really really quickly
that knight coming to c6 bishop coming to h7
just as an example you know you could
just see the whole position collapsing so
a move like e4 needs to be treated very very
precisely let's say you're playing rook after d8
but now the bishop could come out to f4 or
you could consider pawn to e5 pushing away
that knight because that pawn's untouchable
bishop f4 bishop d but now e5 is crushing
now e5 is crushing and it is the c6 pawn
that ultimately is going to do alessia in
if remember to play z5 it's it's amazing how
much this position has changed over the course
of a couple of moves because we're just saying how
how good alicia's position was and i was praising
her e5 move but in actual fact that e5 move it
needed to be uh followed up very precisely because
you are changing the nature of the position by
pushing a pawn in the center and that one mistake
of allowing white's knight into the position
it's collapsed now unfortunately just
really now gone totally downhill uh for for
alicia and this is going to be another win
on the board for roberto it is and just to come
back to that pivotal moment when uh it's and this
is very instructive because the queen is often not
very good when it's sort of dangling around in the
center queen takes b6 this may look less appealing
than taking with the knight and then centralizing
the queen but that knight in the center in point
of fact is actually much much more effective
once alicia centralized her queen that queen had
to go back some tempos were lost and roberto was
able to strike with e4 and then e5 here he's up
in exchange the game is not quite over simon some
precision still required but uh it looks like
he's confidently kind of carrying this one home
i mean uh obviously white has the the material
advantage here white doesn't really have any
weaknesses you know when you're playing you've got
to try target weaknesses see where the weaknesses
are can't really see many in white's position so
it should be a win for white but again talking
about tactics for the match alicia had this big 15
point lead at the start and you want the time to
drag on as much as you can is part of this part of
the process and uh i and she's still got chances
this is yeah as you say there's always chances
with pieces on the board the queen's on the board
a mouse slip you never know we've had one mouse
slipped from alicia maybe roberto should respond
by giving a mouse slip away here i don't think
he will but it's always possible in it always is
in bliss chess yeah and you know some people say
uh you know you should allow a take back quota for
now slips in my opinion that's part of what
makes it interesting the technology uh is is a
legitimate part of of being good at online chess
and i think that just adds a wrinkle i get i get
that it can be weird but uh i think again i think
it's interesting the problem here with alessia's
position isn't only the fact that she's down in
exchange look at that knight on d3 that knight has
no escape squares so roberto is simply threatening
bishop back to f1 trapping that knight winning it
unless oh and the move f6 trying to create a
little helipad for that night well now the other
night drops so that's the problem with having
these minor pieces that are kind of dangling
all over the position bishop f1 here would
end the game immediately would win the night
yes it's looking bad and you know throwing a
knight into your opponent's position like alicia
has done with that night is a very brave and
often good thing to do but it has its drawbacks
you can get caught in your enemies territory and
uh and you won't be to save your troops and that's
gonna happen to that night now now i think the
next game i i feel is really important actually
because it's starting to roberto starting to
sort of dominate where he in in this game and
the other games played very well here but alicia
in a in the only two other white games she had
has got very good positions and she's played
very well she's got white again if i was roberto
by the way i wouldn't play the same opening i
agree 100 really not working the only defense
if he does though i i think alicia has to has to
try to get something on the board and the next one
to stop this match sort of really you know going
the wrong way it'd be my opinion how stop the rot
you need to you need to do that i agree i think
there's something to be said for sort of tilting
the opponent playing the same opening even though
you're not getting great positions uh but it can
be very frustrating when you're just unable to
refute uh what you know is an unsound line uh with
that being said i think that's not the emphasis
for roberto he's trying to get combative positions
and as far as i know he he's got a pretty wide
opening repertoire so something like a sicilian
or even a french you know a mainline french would
would offer up a relatively unbalanced position
and would be somewhat more sound alessia has shown
that she is very much capable of handling herself
in these tactical positions so roberto's got to
get something a little bit more sound but here
we see a couple more moves have to be made
here i really like what alexia is doing here
queen h6 queen takes hp trying to get to white's
king wearing him down a little bit one way to play
this would be actually nothing occurs to me off
the top of my it's not that easy to find a move
here that's totally watertight maybe queen to f4
attacking that rook and if rook h6 and queen to
be it is going to be a background checkmate that
seems like one method but roberto and that's what
he does uh again this is very impressive
finding this move because white has a lot
of options there that the time was ticking down
and like so i like what alicia tried to do there
and this is a very good technique if your
position is clearly bad or it's going wrong
there's no point trying to keep fighting it out in
a positional game you might as well just throw all
your pieces at your opponent's king even if you
know it's going to fail it's like a last sort of
kamikaze attack and these attacks can sometimes
throw your opponent off guard and get you
unexpected results so totally the right idea but
um roberto's handling it very well he seems very
calm doesn't he i'm impressed with how he's
not phased at all at this moment or any moment
drawing this match really no he's he's coming into
this with experience and he's playing very level
had a chest he's had so many of these especially
with black quite a few of these dubious positions
and he's found creative combative ways to defend
them and he's gotten out of bad situations he's
capitalized on good situations so he's doing
he's doing everything right here we see a very
clinical bringing the queen back not quite for too
many pawns that b pawn is what's going to decide
the game you can even push it to b5 right now you
don't really need to defend that g pawn but if you
wanted to you could drop your yeah he does alessia
trying every last chance but a rook is a rook and
that rook is right behind that passport there
it comes b6 b7 b8 close your eyes promote the
pawn win the game it's nice when you've got such
a simple plan as well isn't it just just push push
the b pawn get a queen and uh there's now just
be a little bit careful obviously there is one
one second left look at the time the
times a little bit time he's gonna move
yeah and hither another the queen goes
but now finally yeah yeah good moves
but yeah he's gonna start that this is so
calm i have to say and uh queen 67 yeah yeah
very calm player from roberto i'm very impressed
with that and so this game i think really is
alicia's chance okay she's yes she's lost five
on the drop now and she's got the white pieces
i don't think roberto should go for this b6
plan it hasn't he's done it against this is
and that's because you said that you know he was a
sign what is simon going to tell me not to do let
me do that that's always the way well but i mean
just play and i really don't think alyssia should
try anything different she no she went free last
time okay it's a similar setup isn't it this one
um i guess it's very saying but she is getting
good positions here daniel and this is a good
position to start your comeback and you know
how this good position would be best enjoyed
with some coffee which i'm going to grab right now
yeah i'll give you the wheel for about 10 seconds
yeah no no worries so one thing i don't really
like what white's done here now is that check with
the bishop um because the problem white has if
you look at the the bishops on the light squares
in this kind of pawn structure white's bishop is
so much stronger than black's bishop of the same
color because that light squared bishop can
of whites is on the other side of the pawns
black's light square bishop is stuck behind the
pawns in the middle so this check i'm not so sure
if it's the right thing to do from alicia not
a bad position here though certainly not a bad
position because she's got these two pawns in the
center of the position and now um okay roberto is
forcing the exchange there the danger with having
these two pawns in the center of the board though
is that they can get chipped at they can get a
little chipped and that's exactly what roberto's
doing he's chipping at them with the pawn on c5
the knight on c6 and they could at some point
become very weak so i have to say this is not as
good as the other games which alicia has played
from the white side i'm worried that those pawns
in the center are are just weak rather than strong
and you know the wrong piece has been
exchanged the light squared bishop as well
yeah and yeah look at that pawn train that
knight on c3 white would kill for that knight
to be replaced with a pawn and often in these
positions you do see as weird as it is 92 here
might be something to consider because the thing
is and and if knight takes d4 and knight takes
c4 well you could choose between c3 and knight
takes b4 that c puns overloaded so knight she
does it and i've been consistently impressed with
alessia's decision making in some of these moments
the problem here might be the move c takes d4 and
perhaps we could show this on the analysis board
the problem here if you just blindly take all the
pieces and this shows the danger of tunnel vision
focusing too much on one thing okay everything
is fine i've taken on deep oh knight takes c2
and that's a fork so roberto does place he dixie
for alessia we'll have to be very careful here
yeah yeah it's uh this is it's just the pity white
doesn't have that light square bishop you know
it's such a nice piece to have in these positions
and uh um now what is the move to play this is the
question right i mean if black has grabbed that
pawn a little bit of pressure on the c files c2
is weak so oh she did she played oh she fell she
does it i jinxed her i think maybe she sighed and
wants queen c whoa oh no oh well she's giving it
a little laugh there laugh it off get it out your
system yeah oh no she looks tight terrified there
roberto looks even more terrified even though he's
just won a queen and he's giving himself a little
massage i'll pour over yesterday i feel for that
it's a tough match everyone blunders at
times so and she gets the thumbs up then yeah
okay but she's gonna just the positivity she's
focused she's still up nine points and it takes
it takes a lot of strength to remain positive
in a moment like this definitely um i would have
probably thrown a mouse all the way from
charlotte to new york city by this point
but alessia gathering herself and uh you know
roberto yeah he's like did this religious happen
yeah i i she needs to rebuild i mean
this is uh okay we've got 25 minutes
left of the segment my my fear would be that in
the free minute as time gets quicker obviously
roberto who's scoring very quickly is going to
score quicker so i think she needs to get a point
or two on the board in this five-minute segment
um to have a chance for the rest of the match i
mean it's still a big gap still 10 points
in it so you know there's always a chance
with a match like this but she can't afford to do
too many blunders like that again in the future
uh yeah you know unfortunately it didn't go
well there she's playing on which is i think
totally understandable and just to try to drag
that clock down a little bit more and how can
you recover from that daniel i mean if you're
in this match and you just blundered like that
and the score you're on a bad run i mean you must
sometimes have this daniel win you know you just
game after game things are not going your way
but it certainly happens to me enough but oh yeah
well first of all by the way roberto he
didn't blunder the queen back he gave it up
to have an extra rook simplifying his task that's
perfectly legitimate um you just have to you know
it's hard not to speak in cliches but i
remember having several experiences when
and this happens in tournaments i remember the
2016 us championship the worst tournament i've
ever played uh you know i lost the first game to
wesley so uh who is not the most shameful person
to lose to but you know you lose one of those
games like something is really wrong with me
and the way that i'm thinking about positions
like my brain is not working and i would lose
game after game after game and at some point i i
sort of rethought the situation and i said okay
i'm not gonna play a good tournament but i'm
determined to win one game you know it's like
the goalkeeper's glory you allow six goals
how do the how do how does a goalkeeper and i
read this somewhere motivate themselves when when
they've allowed three or four goals it's all about
saving one goal it's not about the goals they've
allowed it's about the goals that they're not
going to allow it's about that one game-winning
goal they're going to save and i think that's what
alessia has to tell herself it's not about the
games she's lost she's just about saving one goal
yeah i i mean that's why i'm thinking one win for
her would be fantastic i mean because that would
be like right way get the win on the board it
changes that kind of energy as well because you
get this in blitz when someone runs good their
confidence rises and they basically want to own
you you know they want to stamp their authority on
you it's quite a cruel game you know you want to
and and that happens when you can own someone
and to break out of that pattern is hard to do oh
look at this she's got the helmet on she means i
like it what kind of helmet is that i'm wondering
this is the war helmet oh so good what is that
helmet is that any idea daniel i'm not i should
i don't know i didn't come across this in any
of my history classes is this like a viking
helm i mean i think it's it seems to be more like
she's from italy is it like a roman maybe a roman
helmet possibly one thing i saw the other day i
watched the lawrence trent match and i saw him
with his weight i don't know if anyone saw that
so he's playing he's playing against danny wrench
and when he got a good position he started working
out with his weights maybe he's getting lessons of
uh you know greg greg there absolutely you know
with his weight exercises but is the helmet the
magic magic missing piece of the jigsaw that's
good feel good you know and that reminds me of uh
unrelated but in the basketball dumb
contest i remember one year dwight howard
uh sort of a famous basketball player
he he pulled off his uniform and he
had a superman shirt underneath it and he
immediately got the dunk of the contest so
you know sometimes it's it's all about
wishing and willing something into existence
uh as alessia again handling the opening very well
here so maybe that helmet paying dividends already
yeah i mean she means business in the game this
is the game come on alyssia we want you to get
something from this game there's only now 20
minutes left in the five minute come on just
get something from it the night magic so what i
like though in the chat hello to everyone on the
twitch chat we're getting so many different
versions of what that what that hat is now
everyone's saying is it is it you know what kind
of hat is it and i'm kind of intrigued now but uh
it could be many different things i guess but
we gotta ask alessia in the post game interview
we'll have to we'll have to see um
so it does remind me like you know
some computer game where you get the magic
hat you put it on and suddenly you're like
your strength the magic hat
right raises your strength
so far it looks all right i mean uh this position
is pretty standard for for what the opening is um
it's it's roughly even i think white's generally
got slightly easier game here with the central
pawns and black has to be a little bit careful of
the light square bishop trapped in behind the sea
pawn so but it's a normal position so far right
yeah totally and you know you see this kind of
structure from several different openings and
here alessia playing b4 she's probably going to
follow this up with c5 we you mentioned the sign
that bishop on b7 is currently blunted by no it's
not going to d6 but it's funded by the c6 pawn and
uh the one problem with this type of approach is
this c4 square and here we see roberto heading for
c4 he's probably going to put plan tonight there
and white is probably slightly better here white's
got control over that square he's going to deploy
his bishop to b2 but alessia's position is very
very solid here if i were her i would probably
put a knight on b6 and i would play c5 so i
try to cover the c4 square and open up that b7
bishop and basically just make small improvements
uh to the position let's see how she handles this
okay i'm going to put my lucky hat on as well here
we go i actually meant to get i've got a profile
i've got a profile which is the psycho cowboy
uh but i brought this hat and it's not really a
cowboy hat it's more of like a rancher's hat from
australia but this is for black [ __ ] i'm going
to join the alicia club now can't you do it but
you're right here those squares on there on the
queen side whenever you make a poor move you do
give away certain squares and there are certain
squares there which white now has control of so i
i it could have backfired that idea right daniel
possibly yeah no i agree but i'm just too
focused on the hat you you're you're just slaying
you're just slaying it it's the psycho yeah
that's like a hellboy used to it used to be my
my nickname on the like internet chess club i
don't know maybe you're too young to play in
the internet no i remember no i grew up with it
you grew up with it the internet chess club was
like the origin of online chess i remember
psycho cowboy you're a pretty unforgettable
figure son wow that's when i used to be
able to play blitz than the years got to me
occasionally but i mean this position okay it's
still on it's still game on right i mean we look
at the structure there's one problem with black's
pawn on c6 i guess here uh daniel this would be
my main worry if i was black here how do you you
know a long-term weakness in the position yeah
right and alessia has gotten rid of that bishop
which used to stand behind it but that's not
necessarily a good thing here we see d4 by robert
so securing central control if c5 then he'll
probably play t5 one idea for alessia could be
play c5 and then go 95 and basically the idea is
once that queen leaves c4 slam down the board
with c4 try to open the position up let the
position brief and she does play c5 i would go
95 for if i was celestia and quickly go c4 save
that time for this complicated middle game some
point you have to trust your intuition 95 here
or a bishop f6 followed by 95. she seems to be
best when she's on the offensive like she had done
in a couple of those games of e4 so i really like
your idea of doing that i guess bishop there first
of all is okay as long as she gets a knight into
the central square and i love your idea of pushing
that sea pawn and that that seems like a good good
move but i was wondering if white could have maybe
taken on e6 sacrifice there but okay now knight e5
mustang for sure 95 and 64. and i actually really
like black's position and there she goes and
then she's done it good stuff will she continue
with c4 though because that could liberate
all the pieces right she gets that move in
very benoni like idea and it solves all those
weaknesses and queen b5 is interesting i thought
about that but i don't think it stops black
if alicia can take and still go c4 look at
these pawns on the queen side that could get very
dangerous for white very very quickly for example
take six look at these connected passers that v3
move is going to be devastating yeah definitely
and they can certainly push out the board and
she's done this and she's played it brilliant
i love this attitude it's like proactive to
the hats come on alyssia do it for the hats
and uh she is a minute and 20 seconds down though
this is a problem she's gotta keep that tempo up
with c4 very complex position very complex
definitely i'm sure it's not last right and maybe
rook takes a five and then try to go after these
past puns by getting behind them with rook a4
something seems off about that though i mean it's
such a hard decision to make here for roberto
and he does take on a5 he's taking it okay
so now black squad decide there's also maybe
c3 yeah there is three okay but he's done exactly
that now what about knight d3 at the right moment
maybe now because if you take it i come in and
i queen my pawn and i'm winning you know yeah so
maybe after the game we'll take a bit of a closer
look on the analysis but i think you're right
simon i think that was the crusher sending
the hat energy sending the hat energy there
the problem is white does have
the pawn as well right so yeah
that b-pawn is fast and f4 and set
by roberto sure forwards indeed
white's forcing alicia to play a good move here
and she slayed it darling could she be winning
here this is winning for sure look at that b-pod
it's path basically the red carpet is the world
but will she win i mean okay she's got only a
minute left she's got a big advantage surely here
her b pawn looking strong things
looking good but it's converting it okay
beautiful well done i wanna alyssia wow this is
a good she needs this win to keep the matchup
really important game and i don't see a single
idea for white i don't see a single rookie one
he's got to play rook a1 okay one b2 rook b1
hope for the best yeah i mean even knight e2
to c3 there was quite a nice little tactic in that
position just uh i mean and alicia has enough time
55 seconds will she play b2 this knight you've
got c3 yeah she has to keep her cool can still
go wrong here absolutely don't move the
bishop because then the knight is hanging
yeah b2 was very important in order to
protect the knight she does it she plays
this is an absolute masterpiece stunning takes d1
don't take the b1 rook take the d1 or distract the
other rook king e1 is forced now but it's a full
rook down or king yeah and rooksy one's coming
anyway whatever happens rook c1 get the rook to
see one and you're gonna be so much material up
this is fantastic this has been a great game keep
the hat on absolutely maybe i have to keep my hats
on now and he's resigned and it was resigned on
hat power absolutely she's not taking it off let
me tell you she is not taking that thing off yeah
so should i keep my hat on this is the question
i mean i don't know i might have to come off soon
i'm getting a little bit hot but okay one more day
only 11 minutes left in the five minute portion
i went by alessia yeah amazing and let me just
show really really quickly that critical moment
in the game um so basically this idea of taking
and going c4 that was critical and then alessia
exquisite play here with knight to d3 you can't
take that knight because the rook is in charge
of defending the bishop but the pawn promotes
and so roberto was forced to play e5 takes the
bishop and if roberto takes the bishop then b2
beautiful position that knight blocking the
rook rook blocking the other rook in the pawn is
unstoppable amazing win by alessia as she extends
her lead now uh two ten points yeah it's such an
important one and uh she now has the advantage of
the white pieces and she's getting she's getting
this opening again and i kind of like what she's
done here daniel because in the last game she got
in problems against bishop b4 so she just played
a3 to stop bishop b4 here which is a nice safe way
and we get this normal structure it's actually
very like a french defense so now uh this this
position after bishop e3 uh probably a normal
french defenses kind of position even mm-hmm
yeah and it's been going well for alessia these
these types of positions i would just go bishop e2
in castle yeah she's played it and the main the
main reason i kind of even though i played the
french defense one of the reasons i like white's
position so often in these structures is that
you've got to look at pawn breaks there's a very
important thing in chess and black has all these
pawn breaks on the queen side but so what your
king's not on the queen side so if black pushes
on the queen side your king's safe but white
always has this idea at some point of playing f5
g4 f5 and if white can ever play this f5 move you
can open up the black king so uh i i think this is
a good opening choice but both players playing
good natural moves as well at the moment indeed
queen to b6 another very typical french but what
is the battle revolver on here simon you mentioned
the idea of f5 that's what alessia is preparing
for black well black can play h5 we've seen
roberto do that before uh that rook on h8 could
stand to benefit in the event of hg4 of course
the h12 opens but the other idea for black is is
attacking that g4 one idea you can actually take
on d4 you can play rook h3 and attack indirectly
the d4 bond by pressuring the knight you could
also we can show this on the analysis board this
is an instructive and actually quite typical idea
you could literally take on g4 a million times and
then have we blundered the queen no bishop now we
have but bishop c speaking of mouse slips bishop
c5 trades the queens off and blacken's a very very
solid end game and in the very end of that end
game you could play g5 striking and chipping away
a white's pawn train let's see see takes d4
has watched that happen see takes deport has
been played that's a very nice idea actually
i mean i i didn't consider that one and uh
it's a bishop c5 oh my oh and the rookie
one with h3 that knight is in trouble
g5 here also looks good yeah out there yeah
actually white's position is the ship extended
barely rookie three is obviously the threat and g5
is going to be pretty devastating i'm telling you
it's a great bounce back by roberto i mean this
is exactly what you need to do you lose a game
do you let it get you did you let it fest or do
you just strike back and it looks like he's played
very well in this game typical french defense
breaks maybe even alicia's g4 is a little bit
premature you don't you know if you're going to
attack on one area of the board you've got to
make sure you don't actually weaken that area
of the board and it could have been better to
stabilize the center before playing g4 easy to say
in hindsight though of course right and i would go
g5 here but now b4 now if i were a lessee i would
try my best that's still not good and i think
then roberto might do that thing i mentioned
with taking everything on d4 and striking away
with g5 breaking apart white's pawn chain but
but alessia's first order of priority is is
to get rid of the tension on this knight and
with that tension going on it's extremely hard
for white uh to make anything happen uh bishop f3
instead yeah g5 looks jesus i love your g5 move is
again we mentioned pawn breaks and when you're
playing the french defense you have to know your
pawn breaks the c5 f6 and g5 these are three ones
you should learn about when you learn any opening
what are your typical pawn breaks in the in
the middle part of the game so you know what
plans you're doing and the whole point of this
move is white center now we've talked about it
the pawns in the center they can be very strong
but they can also be incredibly fragile and if
you can just chip away at those pawns the whole
whole center will just explode in black's favor
because the white king here is clearly in more
danger than the black king so you want to open
up lines towards the white king but now if roberto
terry is any further than b4 is going to be very
very strong what you don't want to do if you're
black is something like this right you don't
want to nonchalantly take twice on d4 because the
pressure on the knight evaporates and then white
is better equipped to deal with the idea of g5
also black's king you can't sleep on that that
king is not the safest piece in the world this is
the last opportunity for roberto to play g5 and
he's a french player he should be playing this
move quickly i'm surprised he hasn't played g5
yet yeah as daniel points out g5 great move you're
just trying to get rid of that main white anchor
point in the center of the board the pawn on
e5 the only one of the only pieces black's not
doing anything the one that daniel's just noted
there can jump into life with devastating effects
but because he hasn't found g5 yet he hasn't
played it again i just don't think he's seen
this idea he's um moved his queen out the way a
little bit of uh a backwards move giving alicia
some hope now g5 maybe for white now i mean
i know that looks that doesn't look great but
you might as well i mean to me to say
you have to prevent it at all costs
i guess you can also try this b4 move again
maybe pray you get a rook over to c3 but
it it doesn't yeah i mean it's tricky for alicia
this position she's played c3 g5 now is he's
getting stronger and stronger because now that
he is it really is now look at these pieces of
train all of them it's begging to be played but
knight a5 is going the other way i mean still
it should be noted black's got such pressure
on white's position that essentially anything
keeps the pressure and i'm not going to c4 where
roberto's doing makes sense it's just that g5
uh and i sound like a broken record but g5
is really strong i really like it and it
also goes by the principle that when you've
castled on opposite sides of the board then
it's all about the attack and the kings are on
opposite sides you've got to look at your pawns
just throw them at your opponent's king so it it
basically goes with a lot of uh it's the right
move to play uh so alyssia is still some hope here
um uh roberto doe is is better in this position
definitely because black's plans are easier than
whites oh without a doubt this is just so hard to
defend against i mean yeah bishop f2 night coming
to c4 and uh you will never guess um what idea i
would propose after the queen moves i don't think
anybody in the chat will ever be able to guess
okay i think it's g5 all right i thought you were
going to get ready to sacrifice on e5 even oh he's
played it he's played it at last oh and there we
go and it's actually at its strongest i think with
that knight on c4 now covering that square and
this just collapsing for a lesson they will get
one more game in uh before the five minute portion
concludes right so the match score obviously it's
still a big lead it started with 15 point lead so
we're just trying to i'm just trying to sort of do
the maths in my head and the mouse there's three
uh oh oh oh i'm sorry that was one of each one
i'm gonna have to put my psycho cowboy hat on at
special moments i feel i don't know i'd only use
up the energy too much um but the way it's going
if we think there's the five minute section
three minute section and the one minute section
it started at 15 nil to alicia that's the handicap
and so you'd think if if roberto can get five
points every section then he will catch up
with alicia that's the way but it doesn't always
work like that maybe it's tougher in the bullet
section but the way my simple mind is working
okay you get a five point advantage or more
in every section you're gonna you're gonna win
the match so it's exactly five points is it no
it's it's less now isn't it oh hang on can i count
well it's a nine minute it's a it's a nine points
uh match right now and they started with 15. so
six points has been made up for roberto with this
last game going on yeah and they've come full
circle they've repeated the line that that they
played in the very first game this sort of queen's
gamma declined isolated deep on positioning we see
alessia playing in very typical fashion night
before when you have an isolated queen spawn
aside playing against it one of the most typical
ideas as old as the hills is to gain control of
the square in front of the pun immobilizing
that pawn for white you want to be active and
that's exactly what roberto is doing you can
see him centralizing his knight bishop bungie
pipe i like what white is doing but unless they're
trying to establish that blockade on the d5 square
yeah i mean this this isolated pawn position it's
kind of um a lot to do with taste um i think that
most strong grandmasters prefer having the
isolated pawns of being in white's position
there's a couple of simple rules to go by
if you're white with the isolate pawn you
want to keep pieces on the board and attack your
opponent's king because that pawn gives you more
opportunities to do that but when you're black in
such a position you want to try to swap off pieces
and try to prove later on in the ending that
white's pawn in the middle board is actually weak
the reason it might be weak is that white pawn
in the middle of the board it can't be defended
ever by another white pawn so it's always
going to be only defended by white's pieces
but at the moment i really i think these kind of
positions are so much easier for white to play
because all you do you just put your pieces
on good squares and you attack black's king
and black has this problem with a bishop on c8
how do you get this bishop into the game if you
can't get that bishop in the game it's tricky
so knight d5 aiming for exchanges seems fairly
logical yeah and it works tactically because
if you try to ah if you say ah but the knight
defends the bishop i can just take the knight well
black is not obliged to take on g5 black can take
the bishop on g5 and in general when you've
got a cramped position trades favor to the side
playing against the iqp roberto instead taking on
e7 he chooses to preserve the light squared bishop
and now this knight uh going to e4 perhaps heading
to g5 or to d6 i agree with the simon i think what
makes this hard to play for black is this bishop
on c8 if alessia can solve that from the bishop
then she'll have a good position but without the
queen side it's very very tricky situation here
for black as also daniel rook a free is a very
tempting move just swing that rook over you know
inside i mean this is the kind of position where
you're white you know what to do you look at the
black king you attack it so you want to get every
piece into the attack and i kind of like this like
swinging rook idea you know the swinger i think
um i think it was jennifer shahad had called it
the rover the roaming rook was it but the rover
roaming rook but it's a nice attacking idea
white's instead playing on the queen side also uh
a decent move to play right yeah definitely and
you got to be careful about the about the queen if
black plays b6 this funny funny line bishop takes
d5 knight takes d5 knight c6 would trap the queen
and uh just something that occurred to me so oh
gosh don't tell me this is going to happen oh no
i'll know you no no no i have a bad feeling you
know oh no have this nickname that some people
give me no no it's not gonna there's no way
this is going to this is i'm leaving please take
with upon alicia daniel nostradamus naraditsky
right i'm leaving a few days with the night oh
no take with the pawn oh no you're done daniel
i think i think you're forfeit you have to go and
find a hat oh my god i can't believe it you found
the main losing line and and it's happened
oh no i'm so sorry oh jinxing jinxer oh my
lance that's just unbelievable but now yeah
that queen is trapped look at these knights
white black and try net f4 but and she probably
will but the queen can go just about anywhere
yeah so what do your friends call you did
nostradamus the prophet the prophets and it
comes from you know pogchamps one when i help
prepare my student charlie who is you know he's
a big youtuber he was a participant in pogchamps
one and he played this well-known game against xqc
um you know another very very big twitch
streamer and we were able to predict a a mate
in the scotch in the scotch game oh wow and the
game followed our line entirely it wasn't he was
the one who decided to take the risk so i you
know i got most of the credit which i shouldn't
have but ever since then you know i've i've had
this nickname so i guess i have to live up to it
so that's some good preparation there daniel
so yeah very good preparation and um well okay
i mean there's not even any point running down
the clock here to be honest because it's the end
of the five minute section to let everyone know
what happens next well we're after a break there's
obviously the three minute section and then the
bullet section so do you think alicia can come
back in the three minutes section i mean this
lead is going to be quite she's still got a lead
but it's dropping quickly right and uh i think she
needs to get that confidence back get a couple of
wins in the three-minute section really two times
oh yes definitely and you know i i thought i saw
that glimmer of increased confidence in her play
especially surrounding that when she put the hat
on she got the mojo back and there was something
a little bit crisper about her play but with three
minutes on the clock you can't afford to take
those long things particularly in the opening so
she's gonna have to decide on what she's playing
she's gonna have to tell herself i'm trusting my
intuition there's gonna be blunders here and there
but if roberto repeats these dubious openings with
black alessia it's got every chance to deliver
another strike with the white pieces so i'm gonna
be very very interested to see how they modify
their strategies going into the three-minute
portion and let's say i'm playing this one out
but but uh it's just a full queen for a piece
yeah i i know alyssia's i think her boyfriend's
a very strong chess player i hope he's there
ready to prepare her because they're going to
have a short break and if i was you know if you
were alicia's second and okay has gone now to
that end i would be like right okay let's hear
you're getting these positions that's why you know
you're getting this kind of you know this is your
chance for the white pieces just try to keep that
light square bishop on the board go for the king
you know these little bits i think this is their
best chance with white pieces in the next section
absolutely and we will let these players have
their pep talks and have their moment to breathe
but all of the most interesting action is still
ahead we will bring you the three plus one segment
coming right up first a very short break and
when we return the i am not a gm speed chess
championship match between alessia sanoramo
and roberto junio junio brito molina returns
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the i am not
a gm speed chess championship brought to you by
chess.com we have the three plus one segment
in this really awesome match between alicia
sanorama and roberto molina coming right up but
first uh what else is coming right up of course
the long-awaited return of the pogchamps
pogchamps 3 and this is going to be absolutely
unmissable as popular streamers xkc and ludwig
make their return and this is going to be an
absolutely insane lineup with youtubers
and very prominent twitch streamers
and code miko joins the fields as the first uh i
mean this is going to be absolutely unbelievable
some of these names are mouth-watering we've got
the return of some this is going to be invisible
and it is coming your way in mid february but
first what else is coming your way the three
minute portion of this very exciting match simon
what are your thoughts on how this match has gone
as the players uh prepare to begin the
three-minute portion um well first of all i
think uh roberto has played extremely well i mean
there's no doubt about that i mean he started 15
points down so he has to play top quality chess
to to make that gap much smaller he's done that
if he keeps going the way he's going at the rate
he's winning he's going to win this match i feel
there has been a lot of glimmers of hope from
alicia i mean she's played some great chess
she won that really nice game with some really
crisp tactics and she's got to remember that
segment where she got that attack in and i think
she's got to go for this aggressive play but in a
way and this is a chance with the white pieces
this is where she's getting good positions and
i this is this could be a very important game
we'll see now the pace is quicker it's three
minutes but she's got knight to f3 okay
so she's changed her setup daniel slightly
yeah and the irano thing is the only game
alessia has won has been to the black pieces
when she sees that chance but she's gotten
these these great positions in this line and
and is there a possibility that she did some very
very quick preparation in that five minute break
possibly because in this position knight bd2 would
keep the tension on e4 there's that fundamental
choice does white go e5 and those are the kinds of
structures alessia has has gone for or does white
take okay so she takes on d5 normally black
takes with a queen here as far as i remember
simon yeah i guess you can take the queen or the
knight here i mean this is a totally different
kind of pawn structure for what alicia has gone
for before as you mentioned that white pawn's
normally pushed up so she's trying to change her
strategy she's going for more open positions where
there's more open lines maybe giving her more
potential to attack and this is certainly there's
nothing wrong with the way she's playing here but
i do like this move queen h5 i mean this is good
aggressive play and in a quicker time limit
game you've got to ask yourself which king
is under more danger and it had with those lovely
arrows you drew there daniel there is some little
problems immediately with the white king right
because black's queen is hovering around the white
king here with some bishops that can increase the
firepower on white's king as well i would consider
95 bailing out into into a queenless metal game
and i'm feeling alessia's pain right now because
i myself i remember getting into this particular
type of position a million times when facing b6
you make some of these nonchalant moves you think
you're just developing all of a sudden black's
piling up on on the king's side here bishop
d6 seems very natural another idea for alessia
maybe put the knight on e4 every trade here
lessens the load on the kings oh but be careful
because knight e4 takes takes and bishop takes h2
that's a pretty scary idea as well so alessia h3
but one thing black can consider at some point
is g5 g4 this pawn is what we call a hook alessia
very careful though 94 like what she's doing
disarming the attack yeah i like this i mean
we mentioned in the other structures where black
has a pawn on d5 in the five minute section that
black's light square bishop was a bad piece but
in those positions black's light square bishop was
better than whites and you've always got to trade
off if you have a bishop for a bishop just think
which bishop is stronger if it's your opponents
which it was black's bishop and alicia has done
this very cleverly she's just changed off that
bishop she also has a nice c6 square here daniel
maybe yeah at some point the white queen can drop
into this square it's just kind of like torches
black around there but the first thing i do here
is white is just getting my bishop out finish my
development maybe as you say push that c pawn uh
and it's it's probably roughly even this structure
yeah but white's got a slight space advantage so
so far so good for alicia but that time situation
is very very concerning this isn't the
five minute portion anymore and unless
they're about to dip below a minute 13 moves
in that's not a very sustainable pace because
this position may seem very quiet but it's kind of
deceptive it's got a lot of potential to transform
in a variety of ways and what roberto is
going to try to do even perhaps now is go
c5 open the position up a little bit maybe
bring the rook in first keep the tension
uh and and alessi needs that time to prepare
herself for the position sharpening up a little
bit uh but let's see how she handles this i
mean this is another big issue with these kind
of matches you've got to bear in mind when
you change from one time limit to the other
when it gets quicker you need to adapt the way
you play and i don't think alicia has adapted
to that change in time it was five minutes now
it's three minutes three minutes is a lot shorter
than five minutes and she's already only got
45 seconds left so she's gonna have to speed
up here definitely 100 absolutely and there we
see it c5 and and this is what i'm talking about
now unless he has to make this choice does she
take on c5 bishop c3 is a very typical response
basically c takes c4964 almost reaches this kind
of karo khan like end game uh where both sides
have their respective pawn majorities i don't
think roberto is going to go for an mdm like this
um what should black do instead something a
queen f5 comes to mind keeping the tension when
your opponent is in time pressure one of the most
effective strategies is not to play particularly
forcing chess you know force your opponent
to be the one to continue making decisions
yeah i totally agree and i think with this knight
h7 black is simply keeping pieces on the board
and 30 seconds now this knight coming around to f4
is that the idea so i think it is keeping all the
pieces on the board alicia now playing quicker
yeah or maybe even bishop b5 get some pieces
off and uh keep the position as simple as you can
that one is weak it is weak she's speeding up but
she might be losing that pawn somehow here
yeah or just f6 is even stronger than doubling
yeah and there we have it the position
transforms so hard to adjust dynamically
and alessia has to drop her knife back c5
wouldn't work because if bishop takes c5
yeah this is this has gone wrong i mean especially
with 11 seconds left i mean she's got to learn
from this one i'm not sure if our opening
choice to be brutally honest was a good idea i
mean she got an okay position she was getting okay
positions in the five minute segment so why change
when you you're getting these positions which are
okay and she could be probably losing another game
here it's only going to be as what's it seven
point difference in score and there's a lot of
time left there's 40 minutes in this segment and
then the bullet section she needs to get that hat
back on daniel the laptop i agree that hat that
have brought her a win in the five-minute portion
i might have to get my i might have to get
my hat on just to give that energy again now
and is that when he put winnie the pooh in
the background of a video it looks a bit
like winnie the pooh it does it does get all the
mascots in the picture as well and i gotta say
go ahead i was gonna say is there any hope in
this position for her not with the time i think
yeah it's it's really a matter of time before
you know you blunder it doesn't matter if you're
magnus carlsen or whoever you are you know in
four seconds on the clock and unless he's doing a
very very admirable job she's acquitting herself
extremely well in time for so comparatively
speaking the problem is you know the game drags on
eventually you're going to reach a situation where
you have to make a decision too fast and here we
see dropping another pawn this is a technical win
now for roberto who himself has plenty of time i
agree with you simon i i think it's easy to psych
yourself out when you keep losing in a particular
variation but alessia's got to focus on the
positive she's getting great positions out of that
f3 system um i think she's got to keep repeating
that but trying her best here i don't think black
too i don't think roberto got in too much trouble
in this this opening i mean okay alyssia was maybe
slightly better at some point and she played some
good moves but it wasn't the pressure she
was getting in the five-minute section so
i wouldn't i if i you know i wouldn't be repeating
this opening for her she's doing well though to
drag this game on i thought it'd be over by
now just because of her time yeah london no
this is not roberto missed a chance i believe to
win a piece there i'll show that after the game
but yeah that bishop now finding a stronghold
on g5 and that king on g6 is sort of entombed
you know roberto doesn't want to leave that
g7 pawn hanging he's trying to finagle his
way around but knight d4 before at some
point is gonna have to be played but
wait a minute oh my god it's a draw
it's a draw defeated repeated moves
unbelievable unbelievable in an accidental
repetition and you could just see him roll i mean
wow wow i think they're both in shock i mean
they're really roberto's in shot but look at lydia
she's like draw where where where's the draw yeah
exactly and unbelievable really really quickly
i'm showing that moment when you could have
won a piece sorry not to interrupt you sam
just in this position knight to b5 easy to
miss but opening up the attack on the rook
and exposing the attack on the night neither
piece can't do anything about that that would
have won on the spot incredible incredible stuff
what a save by alessia yeah i mean that's the
kind of thing you need in the match like this you
need that little bit i wouldn't say luck because
she defended amazingly there that showed really
resilient and i didn't expect her to hold that
one with her time situation as well and uh very
positive uh and we're back now into a position
where how's roberto going to react to that that's
the other thing is roberto going to be like
ah i'm so annoyed i'm gonna crow oh it
looks scary oh no this is already almost
lost for black yeah this this is this is a
bad opening choice right out of the gates
i mean look at the pressure the rook x-ray
and the queen that bishop on e7 is dangling
this is horrific for black even though
the center is open don't be fooled by that
there don't have to be pawns for the position to
be bad yeah i mean that that was quite funny when
we saw the draw in the last game obviously we're
missing over the board play and i hope lots of you
are now maybe new to chess watching this in twitch
you become brave when covid's gone and dusted and
you join your local tournament you give it a go
something like that but it reminds me a funny
story daniel that i was next to a grand master and
he was uh english grandmaster his opponent it was
a young junior who was about 400 points low rate
of them and he offered him a draw you know the
junior offers the geometry or the yeah the junior
offers the gm a draw in a position where he's a
bit worse and the the gm just looks at him and he
says he just shakes his head and he just and you
know it's just that look i remember that look it's
like ah you should not be offering me a drawer i'm
a grand master i just said it something like that
and there's funny drawers i remember another time
when someone offered a grandmaster drawn the
grandmaster just stood up and he looked around
he said where where's the drawer this is a good
one where's the draw um have you ever been offered
like a rude draw at any point because obviously
in chess your opponent can offer you a draw
but it's a little bit rude to keep offering
draws or offer a draw in a very bad situation
so no 100 percent i i have and um i remember
and i have a story that i've shared on my stream
uh and and this was my first scholastic to my
first nationals in in pittsburgh pennsylvania
i think the first time i've ever been on a plane
and i remember this was a big deal this was like
i was i think in third grade my rating was
about you know it was about a thousand so i
knew what i was doing for the most part uh and
i think in the third round i'm playing a kid
and and i remember it was a fried
liver i was playing with white pieces
and uh eventually we reach a position where
i could have shifted my queen he threatened
checkmate and i could have defended against the
checkmate while pinning and winning his night
uh and i missed that move and instead i defended
against the checkmate with a pawn and as soon as
i made the move i started kicking him i kind of
won his knight but guess what he does this kid
he was trying to pull some shenanigans on me and
he says you touched your queen and the reason it
said that is because he thought that by moving
the queen i would have to walk into checkmate
and uh instead of disputing it i said yeah i did
move the queen i did touch the queen so instead i
ended up retracting my night move and making the
correct queen move defending against the mate and
winning his peace of course he started crying
at that point and he called over the arbiter
hey he told me i moved the queen so i moved it
and at the end of the game he started offering
me draws on every single move and i felt bad
of course he was i remember he was crying
and you know that just happens in scholastic
tournaments but uh anyways it was like i had
a rook a bishop in six pawns against a rook and
he was making a move and did you just look at me
as much of a merciless heartless killer as i am
now i don't believe that i don't believe that i
do i can remember a story similar to that when i
was a junior i won't mention the name but i was
playing against um miguel in a competition and
we're trying to qualify for the british squad
under 11 championships uh for the team so some
you know british squad thing and this game was
a very important game the last game going on and
she was known to be a very good player she went
on to become women women's world champion of one
of the age groups and i i was i was beating her
but i think i quite liked her and she she started
crying and she started crying and i was like oh
you know i was like and i just i just said do you
want to draw and she and she whipped my hand off
and all of a sudden the the tears just stopped and
it was like i was like and i learned a lot a lot
of lessons about women at that moment no i didn't
really but it was like literally it was like bang
stop crying yep draw and she got on the team and
i didn't and i was like probably should and you
know you've got to be nasty in chess right you've
got to be nasty you've got to go for the win right
no matter who you're playing so uh anyway back
to the game here and it looks like alicia is is
doing okay con considering the opening that
she's mounting some counter play absolutely
we're too nice oh and but she blooded why did he
jingle rick takes d6 that blender's a bishop oh no
a blunders bishop and just like in the story
you make the move and you defend the other piece
yeah yeah and that unfortunately i mean that was
just a very tough position to sustain for a long
amount of time yeah well yeah i mean she did well
to get to that situation and now the score i mean
okay i did say she was going to lose the last
one so but this is a whole piece right i mean
this is this is massive and your king is in a
bad situation as well so um it's the conclusion
to the story did you at least you know go out
after the game or well i mean at the time still
at the time i was only like 10 or 11. oh yeah okay
it's one of those little crushes but maybe years
later maybe years later i might have and then
30 years later you reunited in a bar somewhere
unfortunately that's only in novels yeah well yes
um it was yeah it's one of those things you've got
you've got to learn to be a bit ruthless when
you're yeah no that's true it's just one it is
a game it's a sport and i think you you learn
that and you realize that the board you put the
emotions aside right so on those things to do and
i think you know even though it's it's natural to
you know especially when you're a kid to
cry after losses you never really blame
your opponent for being for being ruthless for
trying everything they can and the tears are more
sadness on your end and i remember you
know and i was i think i was 11 and i
was playing my good friend sam shankland and
we were playing a tournament deciding game
and i blunder in the opening and i could just
you know and i hated displaying i still try not
to display any emotion of the board but i could
just feel you know your eyes just welling up
and i can feel the bile rising in my
throat and i just i could not stop myself
i mean he had to go get me like a kleenex
because like and and sam tells the story very
well but sometimes you just can't stop yourself
but i felt so bad putting him in that situation
so yeah anyway i mean they do say though that
when you're a kid if you don't cry after a loss
then you're probably never going to make it
it's that's true it's the kids who cry it
means a lot too who are going to become the grand
masters because they get so affected by it they
bounce back and they treat it so seriously so it's
actually a good thing to cry as as it is as a kid
you know um no it shows that you care it's a very
natural response and i i there's nothing wrong
with that i mean i think i tell some parents of my
students that you know i cried all the time after
i lose i think it's you know the kids who care
they they put so much emotions into the game that
uh it's weird if they don't cry after a loss yeah
i agree so i mean now okay so the seven points by
the looks of it if i can count in the match at the
moment and uh we're back now to this opening which
roberto keeps playing and he's got this knight
b4 and this is kind of known to be quite a a move
that white maybe should stop is that right it's
fair to say i mean it's still okay totally okay
for one yeah white's got the center and white can
push d5 but yeah i would i would push d5 asap yeah
okay but preparing that one but now but now
black yeah now black is a little bit freer yeah
so probably a fairly even position
both sides quite solid white has
the the central advantage a little bit but
black has the two bishops black is solid black
can play along the c file and without a light
square bishop the problem is the reason again
if we look at white's position without a light
square bishop it's so hard to attack black's king
because you need that light square bishop
you know on the diagonal pointing towards h7
without i you know in this last move i don't
like positionally because you're opening up
black's bishop but you're closing your bishop
maybe tactically white's going to get some
chances with the knight coming in but seems
a bit risky i agree black's getting so many
and now you're gonna have a very classic
situation about good bishop it's a bad night
look at that monster and by the way roberto
can take on g5 as well get the two bishops but
even taking on d5 is very simple and very
strong i mean in the event of something like
this look at this monster sitting there on t5
controlling the long diagonal this knight on f3
it's not that it's that bad but it doesn't
have nearly the same prospects that that
bishop does and roberto does play it simple uh
and rightly so big time domination here for black
yeah it's this move you can think of that pawn
on the dark squares that alicia moved it's just
released the remaining bishop that black has and
you have to be careful about that your opponent's
bishop and now black has the open c file and
this is this is going from bad to worse this
position at the moment i mean how does white get
counter played do you try to get your knight in
e4 knight f6 some desperado attack might be called
for but i don't see it working you know really
i mean uh i would probably try that when
you've got a bad position just go for it
right and i like this move h6 very
level-headed making some luft for the king
uh i would consider at some point taking on e5
maybe employing that other rook trying to get it
to c3 but you know these positions are just so
so tough to defend queen to g5 is another idea
uh sometimes people forget that an endgame could
offer uh more chances in such a position because
the queen is really the glue piece but roberto
going for rook dc that makes perfect sense as well
94 i would try totally you got
to try 94. i think there we go
roll the dice and this is a good practical
choice here because now the rook can come to g4
if you get a move you know if it's white's move
rook g4 some frets all of a sudden i don't know
that bishop takes c4 that was really hasty i
think it was i mean the you you said how strong
the the blacks bishop was it was much better than
a knight so why exchange the bishop off i agree uh
this is not so bad maybe for white now no i don't
know can fight back here this is e3 and she she's
displayed iron clad resilience throughout the mat
i mean she just doesn't give up she finds these
these annoying little resources and i mean that
in the best possible way 94 is an annoying move
and uh i think roberto just took a little too
quickly without under evaluating fully the
you know the consequences of it i mean she's a
real fighter and she's she's coming with these
tough moves and this is the position where i'd
like to have played rugby for there i don't
really want to go into an ending um uh this
situation it's still still a bit better for
black because i think black pieces are better
centralized right here and and b4 c3 and other
so go ahead no i i i think it's it's
still better isn't it for black i mean uh
yeah the pieces it's all about
the pieces here and white's pieces
need to get in the game maybe queen a8 queen e4
trying to get to an ending is something now that
alicia should do just but you're going to lose f2
particularly now though because now you would win
that v4 pawn at the end yeah go for the ending
go i mean sometimes the ending is is a place
where you can be saved right uh if you've got
a bad position you can liquidate into an ending
just try to swap everything off in the ending
and hold the draw is she going to go for this
no she's come back to her free this is also
a decent way to play right yeah because she's
attacking up seven and if i were roberto i would
i would i mean if you play rook c okay rook c3
that's an actually pretty good move because the
queen end game doesn't guarantee a draw if you
take on f7 what's going to end up happening
is actually this might be a drop because here
you have this key move queen back to f4 let's
see how alessia plays this you certainly don't
want to take that rook in queen end games the
worst thing to do is give your opponent a far
advanced pass spawn so whatever you do you want to
keep this rock on a3 make this b3 pawn as hard to
capture as possible let's let's keep an eye on the
clock as well i mean this is something that's been
a little bit of a problem for alicia and i just
like this simple movie taken on f7 you know
if there's not a reason to grab a pawn grab a
pawn yeah you should always do that just grab
any pawn you can see unless you get chipmated
right or lose material oh that's horrible and
that's not good i think allison missed that queen
f4 idea i think she just spent it roberto can even
take on e5 here but that would not actually be
good yeah you want to take here and it's over
in alyssia panics unfortunately yeah and the
problem with queen endings is that it doesn't even
matter if you're pawn up or pawns up sometimes
it's who's got the more dangerous pawn and you can
see black's pawn is two squares away from queening
because alicia decided to allow it to move to that
square so yeah she she fought back so well as
well this is kind of the frustrating thing daniel
she sometimes getting bad positions fighting
back and then dropping it again you know which
is which is hard but here there's no perpetual
no professionals available so yup that queen
on t2 doing a hero's duty and just to show us
roberto puts the finishing touches on the game
that key moment when alessia could have held
the game uh and the rest will be quite simple
here but just to rewind queen takes f7 was the
key move and what we saw is okay rook takes c3
and i think alessia was deterred by this position
it looks like ah there's a fork black wins e3
but no queen and sorry but that queen just
comes back to f4 uh offering the queen train
and the pawn end game is just a dead draw white
king comes out just in time so big chance there
by alessia is still a very good fight takes
a big chunk of time off of the match clock
but at the end of the day um at the end
of the day that's a win for roberto and we
will take that short halftime break as the lead
shrinks to six points and when we come back the
second half of the three minute portion in this
fascinating i am not a gm speed chess championship
match
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the second
half of this three minute portion of the i am
not agm speedchest championship brought
to you by chess.com we are in the midst
of what has been an amazing match between women's
fm alicia sanoramo and international master
roberto molina it's been a match that has gone
roberto molina's way so far as alessia has only
managed one win but we remind you that alessia
started with a 15-point head start she scored one
scintillating victory and right now uh alessia's
lead stands at six points with approximately 20
minutes left in the three minute portion that will
be followed by i believe 25 minutes of bullet as
they are about to get underway simon your thoughts
on how the match has gone so far and uh now i'm
gonna put you on the spot your predictions
for how the rest of the match is going to go
uh well so far i mean roberto has been very
impressive um you know we could concentrate
on alicia's play which i think is being
positive but just missing a lit you know
a little bit but it's tough when you're playing
someone he doesn't really make mistakes roberto
hasn't blunted he's defended well he's kept the
pressure on he's moved quickly and the way things
are going he's going to win the match unless
something changes just at this rate because
he's only now six points off and there's a lot
of games to go so something needs to change
for alicia to get back into this match and she
needs to get that hat back on get another win
this opening is also i'm not sure this is a good
choice as black personally because it's very easy
for white to play uh and attack i mean one very
known idea here is to swing the queen over to h4
i remember kramnik playing uh ex-world champion
kramnik playing this idea of a rook on d1 but
uh we'll have to wait and see daniel
how do you think it's gonna go
well i i contended before the match and i sort
of agree with you that if roberto manages to
bring this to five points or less he's got to
be the heavy favorite in bullet i remember him
playing bullet as early as the icc days under the
same handle a roberto jbm and you know experience
really shows in in bullets so i i agree with
you alessia's gotta make some tweaks here and
and she's gotta turn things around she's got 20
minutes to do so and to me the reason that this is
not the most suitable opening choice isn't because
it's bad but it's because from what i've noticed
alessia is extremely good her strength is playing
with the initiative and that means open positions
unbalanced positions she's able to find a very
strong resources quickly the problem with this
position is it's kind of a key g sort of you
got to be able to play cramped and you got to
be able to defuse various uh tactical chances
by by white and that just doesn't seem to be
quite up her alley with that being said in this
game she's got the early time advantage and it
seems that she's gotten quite the good version of
this iqp position we remind you night before the
idea is to bring under control the square in front
of the isolated queen's pawn in order to prevent
and we've already seen roberto do this once a
move like d5 which i think he's calculating he's
probably deciding whether to play d5 or whether
to play a move like 95 improving his position
yeah i agree i mean at least this time we saw in
this opening previously that alicia wasn't able
to get her light square bishop into the game and
now that bishop has a very nice square if he can
get to c6 so it's an improvement uh my problem
with playing this opening for black is that in
blitz the quicker i find at least personally
the time limit gets the more important is to
have the initiative and the problem with this
opening is black you are kind of defending white
always gets the initiative in this isolated pawn
position so it's it's harder to play for black
you've got to be more accurate but roberto now has
given up one of his bishops and he's got to prove
why he's done that in in this in
this structure because you don't
really want to give your bishops up like that
unless there's a real reason i'm not sure
i would have captured on f6 there daniel is
there is there a point behind white's play
yeah i'm on the same page and i think roberto
is realizing that as he's dipping almost below
a minute maybe knight c5 here really the only
justification to me would be some sort of
very concrete play connected with d5 i don't
really see that being particularly effective
and we see knight c5 here alessia's ideal setup
would of course be a bishop on c6 and a knight on
d5 that would be ironclad blockade on that square
we talked about that the problem is of course for
her if she goes knight to d5 and the knight is
hanging uh roberto is going to snap that knight
off the board and that transformation of the
pawn structure is going to be beneficial for
for white not to mention the fact that b7 is
hanging so let's see it takes on c5 but now ah
and that's a beautiful idea look at this look
at this very nice where is it tactical really
really nice does this wonder a knight no it
doesn't because that rook on d1 would have been
hanging and black is up the exchange the bishop is
protected by the queen this forces prepare tonight
to go into an end game upon down this is a big
chance for alessia well neither i don't think i
don't well i didn't see that tactic i'm not sure
daniel saw it but i grabbing the pawn playing a
brilliant move this is what she needs to do pray
break play bravely and take take her chances and
yep she's now a porn up and this is good this is
a great opportunity for her i mean it's not simple
because white has control and bishop yeah watch
out oh oh no but it's selective oh but then still
bishop takes e6 that is a miss by alessia but
still black is doing okay here she's just got to
make the right decision in this position i would
try to prioritize the b7 pawn over the e6 pawn
yeah that's a pity that white's
got this rook into d7 because
the there's a threat to two pawns white's
gonna win the okay this is the only way
to defend the poor now very passive
looks yeah very passive defenses maybe
maybe a4 is worth trying right tracks and then
rook 84 try to open up the floodgates a little
bit but black's pieces are so bad here yes you're
a porn up but if you don't you don't ever want to
play chess without a plan you should always try
to have some kind of way to improve your structure
you can see white here has a way to bring the king
in the king a very important piece in the ending
and what is black doing black's struggling to find
a good plan this this is a real problem with the
position and roberto is he's i notice he's so
good at squeezing these positions look at him
advancing the pawn he's making all the necessary
improvements in his position first black might end
up in some sort of a zugzwang and ultimately white
has several ways to tighten the screws further i
mean he could bring the bishop to e4 and attack
b7 he could try to double rooks on the seventh
he's probably going to play g5 on the next move
in order to freeze up black's pawns on the king
side it's going to be a case of two pawns
holding back three pawns very effectively
yeah it's i mean it's not the end of the world
for black because obviously black does have
that extra pawn but um you can't escape from
kind of the prison or the back rank black's
piece is all tied down and white can just
sort of wait until the ideal opportunity to
push the right pawn on the king's side or
try to grab a pawn if white ever wins a pawn
back then black is in serious serious trouble
saying that you've got to break down defense
time again working against alicia here she plays
now this i like it but maybe b4 yeah okay can but
now rook t3 would win that pawn and you know that
rook on d7 is is enough for but b6 wait a sec oh
oh my goodness wait a minute knight c6 she's she's
she's jumping out now they're both shorter times
she's got something he's got that pawn that
a pawn's got a long way up the board this is
her position has improved
definitely two seconds now oh my god
knight c6 is a good move
rook takes b7 doesn't work
he's taking it but that liberates black
completely okay i know alicia's better
got to make moves now
brilliant moves quick amazing
b3 though that rook on a4 now doubling rook d6 is
coming rook a6 rook takes c6 rook takes before oh
but that pawn oh and once again simon that's
heartbreaking but we see this narrative alessia
climbing back against all odds but then in time
pressure just not quite withstanding the pressure
yeah it's quite sad to see because she's
playing really well i mean she she's she's
fighting so hard she gets her kind of maybe gets
a little bit of a trickier position to play out
the opening and then she finds the resources
she gets back into the game but her clock
is playing against her and you can see
white's pawns are just far too advanced here
uh it's an easy win for white but it's it's a
pity because she's getting chances but she's
just not getting enough time to take those chances
unfortunately so and it just seems that in those
time scrambles roberto is more experienced as
as we discussed he's a good bullet player and
chess is a cruel game it's it's composed of these
small moments you you go wrong in one two moments
and and the game is lost and now the lead brought
down even even further so five points yeah she
played so well to bounce back there it seemed to
me like when she plays naturally without thinking
like she did when she was under a little bit of
pressure she plays really well so i think it's
something hold her back in that last one she was
sort of had to play quickly and she she turned the
game on its head she actually got an advantage
so maybe she just needs to play at a tempo
pick up the pace here and just just go for it now
you know there's nothing to lose get your pieces
in okay she's keeping peace on the ball we've seen
this opening before pretty pretty even i would say
but white does have the space advantage she she
needs she needs this one right she needs this win
with only two days she really does the white piece
she's got a nice position here roberto deciding to
take with a knight on d5 earlier he had taken to
the queen a bit of a cryptic decision is now but
now he's going to get e5 in and alessia taking her
foot off the gas pedal here c5 is also good rook
d1 i would bring the the pieces into the game but
yeah this is a i wouldn't i mean obviously it's
not a must-win in the strict sense but you know
if this gets down to three points uh before the
bullet you just you know yeah you start thinking
that roberto becomes a very very heavy favorite so
let's see how this is handled like you mentioned
roberto bullet he's got a history of bullet he's
he's very strong anyway he's playing well uh and
you've got to think that this year is going to be
really up against it in that segment so she
needs to she's at least coming forwards now
she's still playing good chess here but she needs
to do something to get a victory she does an ip5 a
bishop v8 that's a nice little move disarming the
knight and then you can play a6 later if necessary
one thing i do like is her tempo has quickened
here so she's playing playing a much much
speedier than she was which which is a good sign
so she is playing natural and she's playing well
at the moment uh black's very solid at the same
time all the black's piece is nicely centralized
in white with their last move trying to double
rooks on the open file which is a normal idea
to do um and now an interesting
decision there black exchanges off
with this crafty night maneuver daniel yeah
and we've actually seen a similar idea what
roberto's going to do i think is it we can show
this on the analysis board he's going to go a6
and i think he's going to put that queen on
c7 that's going to be a weird double attack
where knight f3 and queen h2 is going to be a mate
threat oh that's something really to be on there
watch out for because you could defend c4
without seeing that oh don't get queen h2
checkmate oh that would be ridiculous then i'm
definitely leaving if that actually happens
it's the kind of trick that's very easy to miss it
really is you you know you could show that on the
board daniel because he might just play bishop b3
in that last yeah or c5 yeah and oh boom you know
it's tunnel vision you look at this fire this
boom and that double power the queen of bishop
striking in oh no and rook takes c4 now is the
threat if bishop b3 then rook d4 knight f3 is
going to follow always he's got to see it but
it's actually bad for white well maybe bishop f4
you have to try something here just be careful
that queen and bishop are so so strongly played
they should be rook d4 this would be horrible
with the end the same tactic as we just saw you
can't play knight and free as black here because
of the white knight taking it but you get rid of
white's defender and then you play the knight in
unleashing the queen so alyssia has got a really
hard decision to see by looks of her body language
i think she's seen the phrase she sees it and the
main threat's not taking the pawn the main threat
as daniel has pointed out is rook takes knight
ah yes and then this one again she's seen it very
nice okay good move she had to play this move
she's found the only defense welled done
the problem is queen takes c4 i'm probably
miscalculating this ah so take a look at this and
we can show this this is very instructive so we
get this mass trade and you might calculate here
ah the knight on d4 is hanging but guess what this
is the importance of calculating just one step
ahead knight c6 comes in that's a dagger because
it forks the rook and the bishop so that works out
for white and roberto going that f3 anyway that's
a good level-headed response seeing that line
we're gonna get some sort of an opposite-colored
bishop end game and uh white's not worse
there i have to say alessia has acquitted
herself brilliantly here she's done really well
there was so many ways she could have gone wrong
in the position and lots of tricks but she's now
doing okay this should be roughly even if anything
you'd probably take white because in the ending
it's often who's got the easier chance of getting
a past pawn that they can make a queen and white's
sea pawn has that potential at some point to come
on but with that last move black activating the
knight that's a very clever move yet again by
roberto he's playing very good chess at the moment
he is and i would have gone bishop a4 with alyssia
if i were her and and tried to stick a knight
on c6 get that initiative before black plans
tonight anymore now it's it's amazingly
very hard to defend against against these
weird night jumps unless you're trying her
best but that creates its own weaknesses
and i would drop the bishop
to g5 and then perhaps to f6
in the event of h4 yeah and now an ic3 is a threat
followed by bishop takes d4 and a fork on e2
yeah there's still some tactics here rook f2e1
maybe but look at the time again yeah this is
going to be an unsustainable here yeah i mean this
is the place if you find your way through some
early tactics it tanks a lot of time and that will
pay later on in the game and this is something
which as you can see from the the facial reaction
there is a slight problem it's it's killing her
unfortunately she's she's making good decisions
the middle game but then the game liquidates or
reaches a complex stage and with 10 seconds
it's just impossible to monitor all the tactics
but roberto took all credit to him yeah he's
doing a great job definitely he certainly
certainly to me daniel looks like a guy who
could go very far in this competition i mean
he's playing calmly he hasn't shown any nerves
he's quick he's kept the pressure on he's never
really been in too much danger right of losing
he's lost the odd game or you know the odd game
uh but he's he's really been impressive so far
absolutely and he you know you might look at
the games hey he's is he really doing anything
brilliant he might not be doing anything brilliant
but in matches like these it's all about
consistency he's shown versatility ability
to play different kinds of positions he's defended
very well he's conducted the initiative very well
and uh his positional understanding has been
consistently impressive these iqp positions
uh it takes a lot of skill to handle those
quite as well as he has and he knows how to
push you know he he will lose some advantages
but but he keeps as you said he keeps us calm
and he's able to layer on the pressure even when
he's let go of some of the advantage yeah i mean
he knows where to put his pieces and that's
what chess is about sometimes you can see even
when he's short of time he has that natural feel
he's creating problems creating problems spotting
tactical ideas and he's just keeping the pressure
on alicia and uh now the gap shortens yet again
and there's only five minutes left this could
be the last game there's still a chance let's
not give up on this here yet there's a one minute
section after this she is in the lead in the match
come on unless yeah so i get the hat back on
he needs to get a win now okay every time i've
won the hatch he gets a win we've got to put it
back on got to go back on crocodile dundee style
rather than a cowboy style i think come on for
a win for alicia to get the match into the last
stage give her a chance b4 again this is kind
of like a normal opening and uh this b4 is a
clever idea right again very clever but i think
problems i actually do think the black can take
and there's some complicated lines
and then you can go b5 and oh wow
wow that's diagonal but unless you're going
to five which also seems very sensible
white's pawns become really really weak and this
is exactly the kinds of positions that she wants
to get open and and she has the initiative but
roberto has been so good at keeping his composure
in precisely these types of positions but the
hat for the win the hat for the black for the win
nothing against roberto but i want alicia to be in
there with the last part of the match so it's kind
of a close match this is the position where you
can think about going h5 if you're or you can just
play something sensible is that free pawn the
hat for the win the hat for the win come on up
castles and black is up a pun for no compensation
come on the hat for the win white's queen side is
in shambles bishop d4 is an idea queen f6 i
mean this position caught a whole ninety-five
ninety-four bishop f5 this might just collapse
forward and just just to be clear you know we're
never rooting for one player or the other but we
want the match to be close and you know it's it's
always more fun that way bishop at least had a
very interesting [ __ ] bishop f5 in this position
let's just show that quickly wow hard to see but
b5 traps the queen oh oh that's a lovely tactics
very nice oh g5 get that knight out of there and
a fourth something like this anyways where alicia
has played this perfectly well she's winning
here she's winning i mean look at her pieces
all her pieces are just dominance
look at the bar the hat for the win
oh my goodness b5 wins the wins material b5
material b5 is a lovely idea has she played
92 knight c4 what's the queen ninety-four will
she fight it or knight c2 wins the rook which
one's it gonna be is going to be a queen trapped
if she goes knight c4 she's got two minutes left
come on he's got plenty of time to think about oh
look at this line knight c4 queen takes it and now
kaboom oops sorry not bishop of five of bishop
c8 perhaps the queen look at that beautiful way
to attract that queen what a movie will unless
you see it she's got plenty of time she has to
get this one this is a golden opportunity she
has to win this game i had simon that has it's
a hat for the win i'll tell you knight c2 is also
a movie okay it should be good enough it should be
good enough but i'm a little bit worried knight c4
was ending it immediately yeah i agree you want to
you've got to take your opportunities and she's
gone another decent move don't miss h3 though
h3 is a threat that i don't have to be less
safe than it appears queen okay bishop d4
could be coming she's relying on some tactics
here she's still winning she's still winning
but the advantage is just slipping a little bit
it is she's down on time if she lose this one
oh no no she's moved her queen
into the line of the bishop oh okay
and you can see that oh that that hurts physically
hurt oh and now things are collapsing oh no no no
ah this has gone wrong i mean like you're
losing you've got so many pieces on pre here
you gotta move the bishop though get that knife
move the bishop to f5 okay save the villagers
she's she's played it okay that's the only move
that's the only move to keep in the game because
all her advantage is gone she's still in
the game which she's got under a minute
it should be three though bishop d3 she's
still doing well i think she's still doing
one queen c2 no she is we can see that on
the bar i mean she's got that initiative
for the piece it's clearly full compensation
that knight might not be getting out of there
the problem is the time again simon it's that
clock it takes down on her and then by the time
you know she gets 20 15 seconds for her critical
position this is the problem you know like as soon
as she gets under half a minute she this is where
she starts to make blunders historically so she's
going to have to play so well here i mean i like
this move she's got pressure she's doing okay but
it's the 30-second mark where you your
thinking becomes so quick he wants a nice move
and using up that back rank if a lesser takes
that queen is going to leap into e1 the knight
on d7 may be trapped but it could be an asset
in an attack and look at that 20 seconds left oh
you can't take the knight because it'll be
checkmate as well roberto has played so well
in this game he really has 94 is another very nice
move oh there's a nice tactic there isn't if you
take the knight there's nine ninety-six maybe your
night of six yeah some ten seconds there we go
okay now this i mean you have to try i mean look
at the time have to try this move hoping for queen
queen somewhere queen c yeah queen c 3 when she
won i would take this and then i would go bishop
you maybe four seconds though h5 knights bishop
f2 bishop h4 look at this maneuver get that rook
but not here okay ah one second dang not enough
time g6 may be a bishop before roberto is going
to get that night out he's going to medevac
that night somehow beautiful move by herbert
wow and let's just show that that what i'm telling
that knight c4 that would have put the game away
that is just pain and let me just rewind back to
that moment knight c2 who who can blame her for
making such a tempting move but always you see a
good move look for a better one knight c4 taking
away these squares queen has to take the punter
now the cleanest boom goes the dynamite back to ca
queen has no squares white can't even give the
queen up for more than a piece that would have
ended it a heartbreaker absolute heartbreak uber
all credit to roberto insane resilience such a
nice way to win the queen there daniel as well
that that bishop coming back but anyway it's not
over yet but there's been some chances that alicia
has missed unfortunately there's still still
some chance daniel right oh absolutely there's
still a chance there's the bullet segment and uh
historically we know that anything can happen
in the bullet but after such a scintillating
three-minute portion players need to catch their
breaths we need to refill our coffee seat belts
fastened and mandatory don't go anywhere when we
come back we have the final bullet segment of this
i am not a gm championship match-up between
alessia santoramo and robert roberto molina
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the i am not
a gm speed chess championship brought to you by
chess.com we have the final bullet segments of
this amazing match coming up but before we jump
into that we wanted to remind everybody if that
arena king's season six long awaited is already
underway there's a 20 000 prize uh dollar prize
fund everybody's playing we have picaro alireza
all playing a couple of them there's tons of
prizes tons of hype you certainly don't want
to miss it and the next arena kings is tomorrow
friday at 5 p.m pacific 8 p.m in the evening
eastern time but we'll get to that tomorrow but
right now we have the bullet segment the final
25 minute portion of this match between alessia
santoramo and roberto molina match that has been
really really fun to watch it's featured some
very high level chess and simon roberto molina
has succeeded in bringing alessia's initial 15
point lead down to three that's i think as much as
he could possibly hope for before the bullet yeah
definitely i mean it's still a chance for alicia
we're going into the bullet stage very shortly
but uh roberto's play so far has been incredibly
impressive he's he's he's been like houdini when
the pressure's bad he's survived he's finding
practical chances and he's just playing good chess
alicia has also had had had her opportunities but
her time handling is meaning that she's sometimes
not being able to grasp those tactical moments
it's going to be tough in the bullet but it's
still possible for this year to keep the lead
definitely i'm not too familiar with i mean i
know alessia plays a lot of blitz on on her stream
uh i'm not sure how much bullet she plays it's
going to be very important as we discuss to adjust
immediately no more long things it's all
about intuition it's all about snap reactions
alessia has shown herself more than capable of
playing that kind of chess but she's going to have
to embrace that completely and here we see another
e6 v6 that's where roberto has chosen basically
all matched long a very interesting position but
alessia doing very well she's about to push d5
here and this is looking very dubious simon for
for roberto in the early going look at this this
is losing for black a really promising start this
is what she needs to do i mean she's got a major
center pawns in the middle i love the idea of
pushing harry as i always do throw the h pawn down
though castling is okay this is the kind
of position she needs to convert she's got
a three-point lead you know if she makes it four
points this she's still in it she's still in with
a shell she's gotta win i mean i keep saying she's
gotta win this one but with a position like this
you have to win one positions yeah anyway no but
this move d6 i also thought about the problem with
that move and unless you're taking too much time
here the problem of that move is that it gives
black's knight the c6 where so it might have been
a little bit hasty but still i mean this is a huge
initiative for wayne very very hard to play in a
bullet game for black roberto might just castle
here he might scramble to try to complete his
development i would still consider pushing harry
at some point here or maybe pushing frank oh good
old frank the porn this is also very intense one
night just dive in go for mate go for late don't
look at the queen oh yeah okay here's frank oh
get between the knight f7 queen h5 and knight
f7 is a crusher come on she's done it okay
it's crushing she just got to play this one
don't ever go back knight f7 just really quickly
taking the legs off of the knight and then the
battery is just checked made in a couple moves
it's still still good for white but one gets the
sense that you just missed a huge opportunity
that was a major chance to me she's still got
this lovely pawn structure but now roberto
and that is just an unbelievable turnaround
simon yeah it's that was that was rather
tragic actually if i mean okay there's some
chance here but if you look at the position
when she had all her pieces around her opponent's
king you just look at ways to blast your
opponent's king opening even if it's a sacrifice
just go for the attack and i think you know
it's when you've lost a couple of games maybe
you're mentally thinking a bit more negative
and and that's why um that's why she didn't go
forward so it's that negative thinking i mean
this line you're demonstrating daniel
completely winning for white there yeah
it was a is a big opportunity huge and that would
have pushed the lead up to up to four points and
most importantly there's only 25 minutes of
bullet and that is a heart heartbreaker for alicia
i can see some people in the twitch chat
mention this as well and it is really how
cool is roberto he has proven i think as well
it's not not just that he's been playing great
chess but he's been very calm even there
he must have realized he's completely lost
but he moves instantaneous and soon as a position
changes and he takes his opportunities you've got
to take your opportunities the score now
only two points in it 21 minutes to go
well i you know i don't like it something's
gotta something's gotta change right right
something i mean the thing is uh my coach would
often tell me this one of the keys to defending
narrow the path narrow the path to your opponents
uh to your opponent's victory force your opponent
to find an only move and if they don't find it
then if they find it you tip your head if they
don't find it you get a chance that's what he
did with knight takes step seven as soon as
alessia missed that roberto pounds immediately
and he has been doing this all match well yeah
he has he's been taking his opportunities when
they're not grasped and that's all you can do when
you're in a bad position uh it seems like he has a
slight advantage here but nothing too bad at the
moment um and again with 20 minutes left that's a
fair few games of bullet so alicia has to win
if she's got any chance at some point she has
to win a game or two to keep this match alive
at the moment she's playing well though i mean
she is she's holding it together i mean the thing
is in a lot of these games daniel she seems to be
even out playing roberto and she's getting good
positions but it's just then just letting it slip
through her fingers not finding the killer blow
and that's an important skill to have you've got
to find the knockout blow there's not much time
in your clock i don't like the way this is going
white dominating the open fire seven yeah it
doesn't look good this the black king slightly
weak and yeah as you predicted that is going
to win at least a pawn in the position queen
e7 would one would lose a queen to rook d7 i mean
black is a cool trick there queen e7 or d7 king fb
but um it's just that shouldn't be good enough and
now the clock ticking down rookie seven and now
um queen takes e7 is just crushing because
these rooks are just rook d7 is unstoppable
and if king f6 rook d7 is going to win the queen
wow that's a cool idea here by roberto and now
alessio forced to give up her queen and it's
off yeah and you can see from her body language
as well you know it's getting to her a little
bit i mean it would be and it's very easy to
get demoralized at this stage i mean obviously
now roberto massive massive massive favorite
yes but you know i don't see her coming back
from this but you know you've got to keep trying
she's got another white just do the same opening
you did before carragher understand and one of the
most solid solid car cons available in the knight
f6 faragon yeah so night's coming out and now okay
one point in the in the match now 18 minutes
to go more pieces get exchanged i expect more
comfortable black gets in these kind of positions
yep it's a slight edge for a way but but roberto's
very experienced clearly in these structures
they've had these structures arise frequently
almost every game through the french and through
the b6 lines that roberto has played super solid
position but the battle revolves around who
is going to be better prepared when c5 comes
that's the question the position kind of explodes
it sharpens up uh and and what black is relying on
here are these these sniper bishops on c5 and v7
yeah i'm not sure i like that f4 move because it
it actually gives those bishops more
power i mean it's an aggressive move
but it's quite hard to make use of the pawn on
f4 here and now black again creating threats
okay well this is this is i mean okay black's
gonna win the exchange but at least the white
queen has sneaked into black's position
so any chance to use that queen because
you see the problem is these two pieces
would have combined by that queen on c7
yeah it's guarding the g7 square and it's very
very hard and the pawn on f5 is putting the
bishop out of commission oh bishop g2 is going
to be a crusher here or even knight takes you to
those bishops you did call them sniper bishops
and they're they're looking pretty deadly there
aren't they look how strong they
are i mean you're even threatening
to nearly move that knight and give check mate
because of the bishops it's a crazy position but
the best chance here is probably queen takes
night i mean yeah you know just just get the
two pieces and pray um but i think this is going
to level level the score now 17 minutes to go
so bishop i mean roberto is very impressive he's
looking more and more impressive as the time goes
yeah i am really going to be a contender for the
whole competition he is without a doubt i mean
he's so versatile we've seen versatility has
been a winner across the board bishop before
his check made in a couple years brilliant
look at that wow oh this is a nice finish
look at that finish i'll show that again oh look
at those sniper bishops you talked about them
unbelievable bishops there um score is level yep
and it's a tie game time match 16 minutes to go
hey it ain't over till it's over but it's just
one gets the sense of robertson so confidently
yeah he is uh his confidence is growing he knows
it's a tied match now he can kind of relax as well
can't you because it's like you're always behind
now he's tied it's like right okay i'm now i'm
it's the first time in a match he's been tied
he could go ahead if he wins this one then
it's just gonna get worse and worse for this year
unfortunately yeah and playing prophylactically
his positional understanding too has been pretty
impressive he stopped some of these ideas alessia
trying to get this f5 idea and this knight h5927
is a very good maneuver by the way to prepare f5
uh now the ball in roberto's court uh because
this king's indian these kings indian types of
positions because blind you mentioned this earlier
simon these positions where you have a set kind of
series of moves a simple plan like that f6 though
but they can be a lot easier to play even if
uh your crowns i think unless he's trying to go
knight g8 at some point but that's to a little
bit too much preparation because now robert is
going to go knight b5 and he's going to start
operations on the queen side yeah i agreed i mean
you want simple plans and uh i think that f-borne
should have been shoved down the board and every
kind of tempo makes a difference here but okay
what is knight d3 okay okay all now that is the
exchange it is the exchange and f5 has come okay
you can see this is the first time i've seen some
emotion from roberto as well i haven't seen him
crack like that but can she win one positions
that's the point she's got to win she's already
made a mistake though because that knight on e4 is
now a huge blockade rookie on but look at the time
situation roberto also one of the first times he
is down seriously on the clock in the bullet game
can alessia hold it together maybe look half seven
get that rook in there defend the seventh rank
don't take too much time easy to say hard to do
night a seven now an idea i i don't mind there's
so much like because at least it's a proactive
move get the rook into c2 i think this is good
you know it's still she's still in there with
a shout here um she's got the time advantage
but roberto again this is what roberto's
doing he makes a blunder okay he shook
his head next move he's back on the game bang
bang and uh this is where he's been so impressive
he's just such a he's a strong character you can
tell that immediately yeah experience experience
strong knows how to bounce back this last move
don't necessarily like with the i mean okay it's
still unclear 14 seconds yeah between f7 is a
good move doubling up 94 come on get in look at
that knight on e4 it's defending f2 rook 62 is a
big threat though and roberto calm as a cucumber
yeah i've never understood that phrase i
suppose it's because cucumbers are pretty bad
right yeah they're cool they're cool they stay
cool they're cool i don't like it but oh dear oh
look after you rook f2 oh come on just punch
it queen comes in the ending i thought okay
not over yet not over yet four seconds too slow
that pawn's unstoppable or is it rook d3 knight d6
oh bishop f6 it's actually still a game black is
winning bro look at this b5 now the other pawn is
going to start rolling no roberto gets his king
into e2 alessia trying to use her rook strikes
e1 who takes the two and that pawn is going
to evaporate and so do black strong chances
oh man bishop is so tragic right i mean just
by the narrow it's not that even she's making
any big letters it's just he's he's keeping
that pressure going all right i mean for the
you have to remember that the gap in their elo's
is quite large yeah it's like is you're looking
at four or five hundred points i think but the way
that alicia is playing is very small on the board
she's getting chances she's fighting back but just
not quite you know roberto has that extra little
gear at the end and this is the first time he's
been in the lead in the match so really alyssia
needs a bit of a miracle now with 12 minutes to
go it's going to be very tough now can we see
that smile on her face and for those interested
in the ratings roberto in terms of p day ratings
he is 24 34 alessia 2160 um of course absolutely
nothing to sneeze at but uh that you know he's
been in i am for many years he's so experienced
and uh and that just tells you know that you can
see the consistency that's perhaps the word
that comes to mind maybe no brilliancies but
uh but he's played tons of good moves very very
consistently very few blonders that's important
yeah i mean he seems he seems to know certain
structures and you sort of see this and when he's
playing black as in these kind of positions he's
going for this pawn structure we're seeing here
this is an important tool to use once you get used
to playing the same pawn structure time and time
again you know where the pieces should go you know
what exchanges to make you even know what endings
you want when you play the the first couple of
moves and this shows his experience and this is
something we all should aim to do get experience
in positions know what you're aiming for and that
is also a factor that that's uh helped him a
lot in his score here indeed and here again a
very nice end game for leslie aggressive play i've
liked the way that she's handled her she's doing
really well she's playing really well absolutely
is and white is better here but and white can
still attack black team a move that could be
quite crafty here is something like knight g4
and then that but there we go and then i could
sack himself on f5 she's playing brilliantly in
this game brilliant yeah i mean when you've got
more space when you're attacking generally keep
the pieces on the board and she's using harry
come on harry get some squares she's playing
really well i don't know about age six though
simon that left that knight on that fade back
okay so this is this is often what she's doing
she's playing this great chess in the early middle
game but around this point her clocks getting
a bit low and she's not getting that final kind
of attacking maybe here there's just nothing
with black defending very well he's a very good
defender as well you got great better every type
of position and you have you don't see a single
game where he just kind of throws his hands up and
says ah you know i'll give her this game you know
this game is not my game every game is his game
every game he tries to find objectively the best
chances that's a quality of a of a winner yeah
i mean he's making it hard in every position
definitely never giving up and that time is still
ticking down there's no attack here the night the
knight on the side of the board is just just a bad
piece here uh and black more centralized this is
often this is another theme i've noticed that
roberto is often just centralizing his pieces
a lot better it's okay putting your pieces on the
side of the board on occasions if they got a real
aim or they're doing something concrete but in
this situation that knight is not doing anything
on the side of the board so it's looking bad
five seconds left as well oh but look at that
this is actually one situation where she probably
wants to get on to the next game right i mean her
only chance okay it's unlikely now of course
but i think in nearly every game daniel in the
bullet section she's been winning at one stage
every single game she's been winning it's the
converting which is the hard part and i think
this is what a lot of people say it's actually
it is the converting of advantages which is one
of the biggest skills to learn it really is really
hard and i can't criticize because it's been
one of my biggest weaknesses throughout my chest
career you just your hands start to shake you know
you start to feel that nervousness you know why am
i not finding the fastest win and nothing is more
frustrating than knowing because you know when
you're winning you almost always can just know it
but uh you know you're winning and you can't find
it and that frustration is unimaginable yeah i
totally agree and and it's it's it's also like
when when you're winning your opponent often if
they're a real fighter like obviously roberto
is in this game in this match they they're sort
of like an animal backed up in a corner they get
their teeth out and they fight they've got nothing
to lose they become more dangerous and you've got
to remember that rather than relaxing which most
people do when they gain an advantage you should
actually be more on guard because your opponent
has less to lose you can take more chances so
converting advantages never relax until the game
is over such a big thing in chess absolutely and
you know people ask well how has just chess
changed as a you know a result of 50 years as
a result of the advent of computers and i think
one of the most noticeable things is just the the
overall tremendous exponential increase in the uh
ability of people to defend bad positions across
the board not just uh in terms of a select few
players but you see players like roberto iam's
gm's fm's almost everybody has acquired this
this renewed fighting spirit whereas sometimes
if you looked at games of the past you know not to
suggest that there weren't amazing defenders you
know like the trojan but uh at you know some of
the lower levels i think the players were faster
to admit defeat they were faster to congratulate
their opponent game role play now you compare
these players to tigers that's just that's the
norm rather than the exception and that's great
yeah i agree i mean it's quite funny because
if you look back at the games of paul morphy
who is the the legend from new orleans and
he was his fantastic attacking genius but
i don't want to be rude but if you look at
the quality of the way his opponents defended
if it was a game nowadays you'd say his
opponents were just weak they defended terribly
they defended they didn't even put they didn't
even at today's level you they would never be
up there and in the top hundred players they've
defended meekly and that skill of defending has
just increased and increased over the years
if morphe played the way he did nowadays
he may struggle if he played the same stuff i mean
of course he'd adapt to the time but defensive
play has just become like as you say daniel much
more appreciated because computers have shown
how to defend certain positions i feel yeah and
we see some i mean i don't think either of us
is suggesting that morphe was anything sort
of brilliant nor diminishing his tremendous
contribution to the development of the game the
guy was an absolute legend the genius but uh still
it makes sense in terms of uh kind of narrating
understanding the transformation of chess we can
uh you know admit the you know the improvements
that have made and at the same time recognize
the achievements so this is not to diminish
anything that he or his opponent said but the
fact remains the attitude really has changed
and it also is reflected in the fact that
there's just more chess professionals now
and there's more people who who take the game
you know scientifically for whom it really is
the livelihood whether they win or lose back then
you know some players were even at the
high levels were you know sort of had
a cigar dangling from their from their mouths
and you know they were munching on a baguette
yeah you know very good paul murphy is this
is a genius play yes i will let you sacrifice
and lose okay i don't know why well that came but
you know what i mean i want to hear more of your
uh you know your you know your representation
so far that's good with morphe i like that that
was a good one yeah i haven't done any accents
today i haven't had the occasion to but perhaps
the chance will arise yeah it's quite funny
though because if you go back to the days of
paul mcmurphy it was actually considered okay
your opponent sacrifices a piece against you
it was considered un-gentleman-like if you did
not accept the sacrifice so you know your person
offers your rook and you're supposed to take
that rook otherwise you lose a bit of your people
be like oh i look at him such and so he's not a
gentleman he didn't accept the sound right exactly
and you know like coffee house chess they call
it and you have the crowd there they want to
see glory on the board nowadays obviously if your
opponent offers you a sacrifice and by taking it
you get a bad position you'd be crazy to take it a
draw there okay that's a good draw that's stopping
the rock a little bit um i kind of like the
coffee house chest bring back the coffee houses
you know absolutely yeah we need more coffee
house crates we need a little bit more of that i
completely agree some more speculative sacrifices
definitely well we do we do have duboff don't we
and people like that so people are still playing
in that way at the moment just a little bit more
um you know refined i guess anyway good that
alicia stopped the rot there and again she's
got a good position here i mean this this looks
to me like black's king is weaker than white's
king the white's king is safer so it must be
a bit better for her maybe g4 just go there is
time for two more games okay so if she wins
this one okay it's a two-point game as far as
last time i checked okay this and she's getting
she's getting ready for g4 here yeah she's gone
g4 traps the bishop that bishop he's trapped
but bishop five actually bishop f5 is still a
chance because that opens up the g file speaking
of copy house chess by the way gotta embrace
unfortunately pawn takes queen as check
which is annoying checks and uh yeah
that's the match that could be well the ee
was even faster but this works rookie two oh
that's a nasty little move yeah yeah you know the
end of the day roberto's consistency prevails but
alessia can hold her head up high she she played
very high quality chest throughout the match and
you know i'm not just saying that's uh you know
attempt to make her feel better she really did
and by the way we are i i think going
to have interviews with the players so
do do hang around for that at the end just be nice
nice to hear their opinions and if you've got any
questions in the chat then that you'd like to ask
them it's probably i'll keep an eye on the chat
probably a good time to throw those questions in
now and so and i just wanted to read off um robert
of course we missed you but gm has robert making
a very astute comment i i wanted to read that off
hey everyone here's my take if someone has covered
every chest of impossible playing chess is hard
alessia has done tremendous fight and even
as outplayed roberto in certain stretches
completely second that of course roberto the
higher rated and stronger player most people
would not even be willing to play a match like
this given that you're about to suffer many losses
but it's a great opportunity to face often as
a strong player and learn from the experience i
think that's a very very good take and that
cannot be underestimated you know you know
unless you knows coming to this match you know
that even if she would have won i mean you
you're gonna take a pummeling and um you know she
deserves tremendous credit for holding her head
up high and keeping you know continuing to put
an effort every single game with that being said
roberto deserves equal credit for for a
tremendously played match that's what makes chess
great both players can take away very positive
experiences from a match like this i think so yeah
i totally agree and um alicia she's played well
i mean you know she has outplayed a much higher
rated and more experienced and stronger opponent
on numerous occasions she's got winning positions
she's put him under pressure and she's proven that
she's got a lot of talent and has a lot you know
she could improve massively from her rating at the
moment so you've got to take away the positives
from something like this obviously it's depressing
to lose anything really chess related but she has
proven herself as a very dangerous and good
opponent here for for roberto absolutely in
some ways i think there's the score line doesn't
really reflect reflect how how close the match has
been it should have taken just a little percentage
of those opportunities she had she would have won
this match and uh you know that's a big thing do
check out their stream channels as well both these
two people stream alicia streams quite early in
the morning if you're in europe i would say maybe
late at night in america but go and follow her
twitch channel and i'm i haven't actually seen
roberto stream ever i'm sorry about that roberto
it might be a different time to me but i know he
has his own youtube channel and twitch channel
so obviously worth following them and um also
checking out what they're looking at live streams
a lot of fun particularly here speak portuguese
uh he's very well-rounded player i'm sure he puts
out uh tremendously instructive content on on his
youtube channel alessia um i've definitely
popped into her stream quite a few times and
you know she's so high energy she puts her effort
into it and definitely definitely worth the follow
uh and that with this checkmate on t6 concludes
and they will abort this game that concludes the
match final scores 21-17 as international master
roberto molina plays tremendously to win the match
and alessia an amazing fight all throughout we
will definitely delve into this match as we will
interview the players so do not go anywhere
we will take a quick break when we return
interviews with these two gladiators
um upon the conclusion of this match
so
and welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the i
am not a gm speed chess championship brought to
you by chess.com the match between women's fplacia
sanoramo and international master roberto molina
has just concluded uh roberto and we have the
players here for a quick post game interview
we're very excited to hear their thoughts uh
first of all uh roberto congratulations on an
excellently played match what would you say
were some of the keys to your victory what do
you think that you did particularly well to guide
yourself to that victory um i prepared some lines
tricky blitz lines and she enters in in two
of dance uh for example the false french the
fake french with b6 and uh i i saw some
nakamura games in this type of position
and i think i learned something and the
other position in the english opening
i prepared that little bit but in
one game it was a total disaster
with knight f5 but i think that the opening
preparation to blitz match help is something
i don't know it seems like you you kept your
call very well um when when the position was
maybe getting very tricky you you were
calculated very quickly and uh you kept
defending incredibly incredibly accurately
i think so well done yes yeah good match
i think we're all curious alessia when you put
that helmet on you won a brilliant game tell
us more about that helmets because we were all
taken by that well actually it was pretty random
yesterday um i went to it at home of the father of
my boyfriend and we went just shortly downstairs
to see all the old stuff and i found this actually
there is a complete set that i was too shy to
to wear and there is even a sword i wanted really
to fight and so but at least i was brave enough to
wear this and it brought log it worked you
won a very nice game when you brought a
hotel yeah it was great wins that that game
when your boot is masked yeah you know so
yeah sadly that i don't know why i removed
it i was just so stupid i should have kept
it on that was the major problem yeah yeah we
diagnosed the reason yeah i mean you played
yeah go ahead i was just going to say yeah you you
played really good chess it seemed i mean you you
got some great positions you kept the pressure
on obviously much lower rated than roberto but
you you played well and uh i don't think
the result always reflected that but
some positives to take away right yeah for sure
for sure now i'm actually proud to that i played
good chess and i got some chances sometimes i
didn't use them sometimes few times i use them and
so at the end i mean international master modlina
i heard that is soon a gm something like this
so it's very strong and i'm happy about
um at least the good chess more or less
uh i saw some games of alessia
he's a very very good attack player
yeah i wanted to attack but it was hard that makes
perfect sense well fine we know both of you are
very tired final question for you uh roberto going
into the next uh matches that you're going to play
anything that you might want to change any
particular ways that you think you're going to
prepare or are you just going to take it one match
at a time i don't have any idea what's going what
will happen but i think i will saw some
openings trick another against larry strange
but i'm interested you're playing lawrence who's
who's very tricky guy right okay okay but you
played very strong it's going to be a great great
match to watch let's see the trick match it's
going to be exciting definitely absolutely well
uh we won't keep either of you any longer alessia
roberto thank you so much for an amazing match we
were all thoroughly entertained congratulations
to robertson very well played alessia we will let
you take your well-deserved break thank you thanks
thanks wow simon we got everything we could
have asked for roberto emerges victorious in
the end but as we discussed amazingly well
played by alessia and uh you know these
matches are so interesting and as we look at the
bracket we've got so many more of them to come
yeah i mean it's it's it's i'm really looking
forward to seeing that you know how roberto
gets on against lawrence because they they both
played i saw both of the first round matches and
they both played really well uh i mean they're
both contenders i think to win the whole thing
uh other matches that we've got to look forward
to well it's just so many you've got yeah made
major streamers in there you've got major chess
personalities you've got young talent what what uh
what a great event this is absolutely and i know
a lot of people looking forward to levy's progress
he's going to play the winner of costa kabootsky
against tanya sasha we could see sagar shah
i'm really excited to see him to see him playing
him a big eric rosen fan and uh greg shahadi not
to be underestimated as well uh he's part of the
old guard but greg's a beast so this is again an
amazing field put forward by chess.com and uh it
just shows that super tournaments are great you
know tata steel's gonna be great but uh this is
not to be underestimated every single one of these
players is putting themselves on the line putting
their blood sweat and tears into each match and
that's really what brings us to to the next level
son yeah certainly it's great seeing that you know
made the internet chess live on for many years so
perfect and uh as always you know i'd just like
to say it's been a pleasure uh commentating with
you daniel and thank you everyone who's tuned in
it's been a lot of fun likewise simon it's uh
always an honor uh yeah i'm a big fan and uh this
has been just amazing and i think we want to thank
thousands over ten thousand over twenty thousand
of you who were taking time uh out of your busy
thursdays watching this match and contributing
to the chat uh this is really brought to the
next level because of you and um on behalf of us
gm daniel meredith the one and only ginger gm
grandmaster simon williams covering the i am not
a gm speech championship there's a lot of action
yet to come we will see you in the next match
but for now stay safe everybody have a great rest
of your thursday and a great weekend and so on
you